there's an app for that
wait hold on I'm Steve Jobs
was a phrase so ubiquitous in the early
days of the smartphone craze that it's
hard to believe Apple actually has
trademarked it was a testament to a
simple and immutable truth about the
world these new touch screen phones were
creating no matter how strange and
obscure the need there would be an app
to fulfill it perhaps you remember iBeer
the app that allowed you to pretend you
were drinking a tall glass of beer for
some reason there was car matey an app
that reminded you where you parked your
car in a pirate voice and who could
forget I am bread a surreal game about
controlling a sentient slice of bread on
a quest to become toast but there's one
app out there somewhere on the market
that you probably didn't download and if
you did well you have our sincerest
apologies because even seeing this video
pop out onto your feed probably sent a
chill down your spine well if that chill
ever even left take it from one
gentleman whose life took a very strange
turn after download adding a certain app
that the SCP Foundation calls
scp-1471 because the sentiment there's
an app for that doesn't exclude
experiencing mortal Terror Joe Lewis an
insurance salesman from Milwaukee had
just gone through another atrocious date
after a mediocre meal and an
uncomfortable 35 minutes of inane Babble
sensing the whole time that she really
wasn't that interested his date excused
himself to take a quick phone call
outside sadly for Joe she never returned
leaving him to pick up the check of all
the many words you could use to describe
Poor Joe Lewis the most pertinent would
be lonely ever since Carol his wife of
10 years had passed away in a freak
accident he'd been trying to find some
kind of way to fill the void they'd been
high school sweethearts intent on
spending the rest of their lives with
one another as fate would have it only
Carol would get that tainted luxury Joe
would be forced to endure life after the
Joy of living had run its course he only
hoped he might be lucky enough to find
love again however Joe was on the wrong
side of 40 and as so many others his age
were already hitched he could feel his
options going out one by one would he be
destined to live out the rest of his
days alone Joe didn't feel like spending
the back half of his life catching
reruns of Seinfeld and tending to his
fish he needed to get out there and
thankfully like the rest of us he lived
in the internet age he had more apps
websites online services and hot Russian
singles in his area than he knew what to
do with so surely one would have the
right person for him he tried them all
Tinder hinge match.com Plenty of Fish
e-harmony Bumble Zoosk OkCupid Friend
Finder deeply lonely singles with low
expectations.com and so much more
however all it seemed to achieve was
setting him out for more disappointment
none of the dates he'd managed to get
ever resulted it in anything getting
serious heck it was a minor miracle if
he even managed to get any of them on a
second date was this it was this his
life now had he only ever gotten one
shot at love and the grasping claws of
Fate yanked it away from him without a
second thought would life continue on
the hamster wheel of loneliness sleeping
getting up eating working and sleeping
again every day getting somehow both
faster and slower as life trudged on to
a disappointing yet inevitable
conclusion what a terrible fate to find
yourself trapped in whenever Joe started
feeling modeling like this he knew it
was time to get proactive again maybe
the right woman was out there there were
billions of them after all surely at
least one of them would be the perfect
person for him he just needed the
perfect app he'd burned through all of
the most reputable apps already and was
now perusing some of the slightlier
seedier options most of which were
likely data mining fronts from the
Vulcans however as generic app after
generic app passed something different
caught his eye the icon was a smiling
cartoon dog and its name was malau
version
1.0.0 this gave him a little chuckle at
the very least it was very different
branding from the rest of the dating
apps he'd seen maybe he had just been
sorted into the wrong section of the App
Store he decided he'd check it out and
take a look at the app's description the
description read never settle for those
awkward feelings of being alone ever
again Malo is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but after just a few hours of mallow you
will soon forget all about those painful
emotions of disappointment be part of
the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute remember the
more you participate the more malau will
engage you your experience is completely
up to you abs absolutely no ads enjoy
well it certainly provoked Joe's
curiosity at the very least he did want
to banish his feelings of loneliness and
seeing as the app was free and
apparently had no ads he'd surely be
foolish to not at least give it a whirl
what's the worst that could happen he
began the installation and only then
noticed that the app had no listed
developer it took up 9.8 megabytes of
memory which he wasn't tech savvy enough
to see any issues with more than
anything Joe was just enticed by the
prospect of finally having another
chance at companionship with Malo after
all it is the next social substitute
whatever that means however Joe's
excitement was quickly quashed when he
hit the home screen button and noticed
that the icon for the app never actually
materialized strange he checked the App
Store portal again and saw that
according to them the app had completely
downloaded what gives was it a glitch or
was Malo actually just malware either
way he was disheartened by the fact that
this immaterial app certainly wouldn't
be getting him any companionship or so
he thought anyway Joe was used to
disappointment by now so he didn't take
it too personally he decided to just
play out the rest of his evening on
autopilot making himself some soup doing
the laundry watching more Seinfeld
reruns taking a cold shower and
preparing to cry himself to sleep again
Malo was already becoming a distant
memory just like all the deceptive
sources of home but one strange thing
happened that disrupted Joe's finely
tuned evening routine he received a text
message this was incredibly strange
because nobody ever seemed to text him
the last text he got was from Carol just
before her accident so it was almost
surreal to hear that alerts sound now
after everything that happened he
checked and saw that the text was an
image attachment sent from an unknown
number perplexed yet curious he decided
to open it his curiosity soon gave way a
to a kind of melancholy Nostalgia when
he saw that the photo was of his and
Carol's favorite Cafe in town they'd
spent many a morning there back when she
was alive treating themselves to a nice
cup of coffee and perhaps a croissant
just seeing it again caused an
involuntary smile to spread across his
face it never even occurred to him as it
probably would have to others that this
could be seen as a little creepy he
hadn't frequented the bakery since Carol
died how would anyone even know that
this place held any significance for him
was it a stalker a ghost or just a
spooky coincidence none of these
thoughts even crossed Joe's mind he was
just grateful for the surprising
reminder of the happiness he'd once had
for the next couple hours things seemed
lighter he went about his evening
checking the photo every so often and
smiling until eventually he found
himself in bed still looking into the
glow of his phone it was such a
beautiful little cafe then he Rose he
noticed something in the picture he'd
been there the whole time but only now
he was seeing rather than just looking
it was in the corner staring through the
glass of the cafe store so faint he
almost wanted to dismiss it as a trick
of the light it was a face well not a
face more like a skull not a human not
anywhere near human long slender and
canine with protruding fangs and vacant
white eyes the Pure White of the skull
was buried in a nest of thick black hair
it looked like it was crouching behind
the door looking out and grinning
whatever the hell it was just seeing it
change the entire tone of the picture it
was no longer a simple reminder of
bygone Joy now all that was radiating
out of that image was a palpable sense
of dread was someone playing some kind
of awful prank on him just then he was
jogged from his contemplation by another
alert a new message from the same number
as 4 with great hesitation he hovered
his thumb over the push notification and
clicked that's when everything got a lot
worse it was a photo of a bus stop not
just any bus stop of course it was stop
c16 the one that Joe always took to get
to work it looked like it was taken
relatively early in the morning but
nobody was there well not quite nobody
there was that figure again it stood at
full height behind the partially frosted
glass that makes up the back of the bus
stop the same large black humanoid shape
with a white grinning dog skull where
the face should be something about it
terrified him on such a primal level
like the way our lizard brain reacts to
some ancient apex predator and whatever
this thing was it clearly knew something
about him how else could it stage all
these photos Joe got out of bed and
looked out at the window down onto his
dark Front Street empty thankfully but
after this surprise nightmare he wasn't
going to take any chances he grabbed a
kitchen knife from downstairs and placed
it on his bedside cabinet right next to
his phone with 9-1-1 on speed dial Joe
lillis a 43 year old man slept with the
lights on that night for the first time
in over 30 years sadly for him the
nightmare was just beginning the next
morning Joe woke up unharmed but he
wasn't pleased to see that he'd gotten
several more texts in his sleep there
was one taken outside of the local
insurance company office where he worked
the strange creature with the skull for
a face was looming around the corner
peering at the camera with its lipless
grin like it was mocking him another
photo was taken at the local supermarket
where Joe did most of his grocery
shopping the frame was centralized on
the cereal aisle bordered on both sides
by walls of garish mascots endlessly
repeated down at the far end of the
aisle was a looming dark figure with
that cold canine skull where a human
face should be there were a few more but
worst of all was the last one it was
taken at the cemetery in the foreground
a headstone reading Carol lillis beloved
wife and daughter Joe was horrified to
see that skull face Beast was rising up
behind his wife's grave long clawed
fingers curling around the top of the
headstone that was the moment that Joe
decided to go to the police about all of
this before things got even more out of
hand he called an Uber to get down to
the station he certainly didn't feel
like he was going anywhere near his
regular bus stop after last night he
showed the photos he'd been sent so far
to an officer posted at the station and
they agreed that there was certainly
something strange about it while the
behavior undeniably bordered on
harassment it hadn't yet delved into
criminal territory so he would sadly be
on his own until then the best they
could do was stay in touch and kept
abreast of any new developments the only
Sage advice they could give him was not
to delete the photo as they could always
be used as evidence in court later if
things escalated this was literally the
last result that Joe wanted out of this
considering how bizarre and threatening
things were getting already he really
didn't want to find out what escalation
looked like in this case but what else
could he do but carry on just trying to
exercise as much caution as he could in
these strange news circumstances he went
to work and tried his best to stay
productive despite the fact that every
three or so hours a new photo would
arrive places that he liked to sit in
the local parks stores he'd frequent
restaurants he liked to eat at the
nightmare skeleton dog thing would be
standing in all of them just mugging for
the camera on one hand every time he
looked at one of the photos Joe felt
like he was giving this freak exactly
what they wanted on the other hand how
could he possibly Look Away what if he
missed something that could save his
life it carried on much like that until
later in the evening Joe may have not
been a genius but he was no fool either
he'd seen too many of those seedy true
crime documentaries about kidnapping to
take his normal route home he took a
real detour frequently checking over his
shoulder the entire time much to his
relief he didn't see anything out of
place good when he got home he locked
every door and bolted every window
nothing would be getting the jump on him
tonight that's when the next picture
came in a photograph of Joe's empty
office cubicle with the Bony face of the
creature looming over the divider with a
grin he could feel his heart pounding
away in his chest just looking at it how
did this thing get around like this how
was it able to infiltrate everywhere in
his entire goddamn life suddenly he felt
a smile spreading across his face this
freak had just messed up big time before
all these creepy photos had been taken
in public places but the one taken in
his office oh this crossed the line into
trespassing the police went have to do
something about it now it had given him
an ace up his sleeve that confidence
faded a few hours later when he received
another photo this time it was the skull
face monster just standing on the
sidewalk the sidewalk that Joe
remembered walking on his covert
alternative route he could feel himself
break into a cold sweat it seemed
whoever this was he really did hold no
secrets from them now more than ever Joe
didn't feel safe in his own home so you
can only imagine how he felt when a few
hours later he received a photo of the
skull face stalker standing right
outside his own front door staring into
the camera it sent him rushing to the
window again to check outside but of
course nobody was there the next day
when he called the police and updated
them on the situation they told him that
they were doing all they could the best
thing he could possibly do was to remain
calm but Vigilant he needed to keep an
eye on the photos being sent to him so
we could notify them if ever he was in
any immediate danger this put poor Joe's
paranoia at a fever pitch even when he
went to work surrounded by his
co-workers by Witnesses he could
scarcely tear his eyes away from his
phone he was a slave to the photos
forever waiting for the next one only to
experience crushing regret when the
photo actually arrived it looked like it
was taken moments before it was sent to
him Joe saw himself looking at his own
phone in his office cubicle with that
huge skull-faced figure looming behind
him he screamed out loud upon seeing it
and turned to see if anything was behind
him but of course there was nothing
there the police inspected the office
talked to potential Witnesses and
analyzed the photo it showed no signs of
any photographic manipulation but there
were also no witnesses around the office
who claimed to see anything strange that
day there was also no security camera
footage in the last several days that
showed this figure coming in or out Joe
Lewis started to feel like he was going
insane and perhaps he was but that
didn't change the tangible and
ever-present feeling that he was in
great danger he didn't come into work
the next day he'd received more photos
like that in the night of himself taken
in real time with that skull face freak
looming he didn't want to leave the
house he didn't want to go anywhere
anymore he just didn't feel safe out
there how could he with all this madness
unfolding there was a time where he
could have said something like at least
it only seems confined to my phone he
might have even suspected that it had
something to do with that strange mallow
app he downloaded a few days prior that
hadn't seemed to do anything but this
situation had evolved since then he
wasn't just seeing the creature in
photos anymore it was here he kept
seeing quick flashes of it on the other
side of Windows in Reflections in the
corner of his eyes always darting a wave
ever he turned towards it it was
everywhere and nowhere it was here just
for him he just knew the police couldn't
help nobody could help Joe just sat in
the corner of his bedroom clutching his
kitchen knife afraid to close his eyes
he could be anywhere it could be
anywhere it could be anywhere we know
one thing for sure Joe lillis never felt
truly alone ever again he always had his
new friend waiting just out of sight and
if ever you're feeling Lonesome and
decide to download Malo version 1.0.0
yourself then you'll never feel lonely
again either it was November 3rd 1991
and Blake Newsome loved his job he had a
passion for organization an Undying Love
of American political history and was a
lifelong member of the Republican party
that's why he took great pride in his
position as a filing clerk at the Ronald
Reagan Presidential Library or at least
he did until his horrifying encounter
with
scp-1981 the worst day of Blake's life
began like any other he was taking
inventory of the archive's wide array of
betamax tapes and making sure that they
were all arranged carefully and
conformed with the filing system one by
one he checked footage of speeches and
addresses off of his list until he came
upon a strange tape that had no business
being there the tape looked to be
completely normal but it hadn't been
recorded on the archive inventory and
there was something else off about it a
single white sticker was on the front of
the tape with Ronald Reagan cut up while
talking squalled hastily with what was
probably a felt tip marker Blake was
shocked and appalled they hadn't even
spelled the president's name correctly
what poor Mr Newsome didn't know was
that he was about to see something so
disturbing that he'd look back on that
misspelling like it was a treasured
childhood memory
standard policy for tapes like this
would be to review and catalog or even
throw it out if necessary typically a
lowly filing clerk like Blake would need
to seek approval from his superiors but
curiosity got the better of him he
commandeered one of the library's
televisions and betamax cassette players
and started watching the footage for the
first minute or so nothing seemed out of
the ordinary
just the president standing at the
podium giving his iconic evil empire
speech to the National Association of
evangelicals at Sheraton Twin Towers
Hotel Orlando Florida on March 8 1983.
however the second the tape hit the 1
minute and 10 seconds Mark something
unnatural began to occur President
Reagan's speech began to Veer off as the
topic of conversation shifted from the
importance of family values to the
Exquisite Taste of human flesh Blake was
taken aback surely he was hearing things
but the tape only got worse President
Reagan began to divulge the fact that he
enjoyed the taste of young flesh the
best particularly that of infants as
Reagan began to go into detail about how
exactly one should best cook an infant
if you want to seal in the flavor the
crowd erupted into modest Applause Blake
started to feel sick he'd remembered
watching this speech and President
Reagan had said nothing of the sort
things only got weirder as the
president's cheek suddenly opened up
into a long bleeding gash as though
someone had cut into his face with an
invisible knife has the speech continued
and Reagan's words became more
nonsensical and incoherent the injuries
got worse too his face developed
puncture wounds like he was being
stabbed skin in some areas rotted and
peeled off Reagan showed no awareness of
the horrifying injuries that seemed to
be occurring spontaneously on his body
this was a living nightmare
the tape came to a merciful end 22
minutes in after President Reagan's
throat appeared to be slashed open and
his insane speech was reduced to quiet
gurgles
it fizzled out into static shortly after
and Blake politely retired to the
bathroom to throw up
was this some sick prank or tampering or
camera trickery perhaps he didn't know
but the tape was disgusting and whoever
was responsible had to be punished
Newsome contacted the police hoping
obscenity charges could be pressed
against the creator of the tape once
they were found the tape was taken into
evidence and the low-level police
investigation into the possible culprits
began
while the police officers who viewed the
tape reported nightmares in the weeks
following the creator of the tape was
never found the investigation truly came
to an end when a superior closed the
case and the tape disappeared from the
evidence Locker this as you probably
could have guessed was the work of a
field agent from the SCP Foundation
anistics were then used to erase the
memories of everyone unlucky enough to
witness the tape including Blake Newsome
who could finally rest easy and return
to his filing work
the anomalous tape was now in
responsible hands it was given the
designation
scp-1981 and given the object class safe
due to its easily controlled and
self-contained nature proper research
and testing was now able to begin and
while nothing about the construction of
the tape suggested anything inherently
anomalous repeat viewings of the video
made it clear that this went far beyond
mere doctored footage of a presidential
speech every single time the tape is
played both the speech made and the
injuries received by President Reagan
change the few rules the tape seem to
always follow are that Reagan never
reacts to the injuries he's receiving it
always has the same beginning and total
run time and the speech is always
corrupted the speeches have been
described as mostly incoherent lacking
any sort of underlying thematic
structure and largely being composed of
nonsensical anecdotes and parables
so not that dissimilar from a regular
Reagan speech but the topics always turn
incredibly dark and have included
torture mutilation death cannibalism
ritual sacrifice genocide and more
the range of injuries shown on President
Reagan in the videos have included but
are by no means limited to impalement
mutilation and some tortures so gruesome
that the details have been redacted from
official files on several occasions the
details of President Reagan's speech
have also eerily predicted the Future
these include successfully predicting
the September 11th attacks in 2001 and
the outcome of the 2008 Russian
presidential election incidentally this
isn't even the only reagan-related SCP
to predict the future
no there's another entity in this
incredibly specific Niche
scp-095 a highly degraded copy of a
comic known as the atomic Adventures of
Ronnie raygun
the Title Character Bears a striking
resemblance to President Reagan despite
the fact that the comment is confirmed
by Foundation tests to have been written
in the early 1930s the comic is set in
the far-off future world of the 1980s
and follows a number of Ronnie's
exploits in three stories
the first titled Ronnie vs Space Admiral
Carter seems to perfectly describe the
events of the 1980 presidential election
the second space assassin mirrors the
attempted assassination of President
Reagan by John Hinckley Jr
and the third titled jungle Planet
retells the Iran-Contra controversies of
1986.
these Comics were produced under the
mysterious and apparently non-existing
company future funnies the foundation
hopes to track down the other comics
from this company whenever possible but
they've had no luck on that front for
now there's only
scp-095 during initial testing
Foundation staff watched the tape
frequently in case this strange
corrupted version of President Reagan
had any other valuable predictions for
the future
however during one of these screenings
one of the d-class observation Personnel
pointed and yelled at the screen in
horror
upon further examination of recorded
footage researchers could see exactly
what had concerned The d-class Observer
so much
while in other viewings of the tape
President Reagan's press detail had
appeared totally normal and this one
something was clearly amiss standing
among the other doll suit wearing
political AIDS was a tall figure dressed
in a midnight black cloak with a large
conical Hood obscuring his face the
figure didn't appear to move in the
footage it just stood there menacingly a
later survey indicated that this figure
would appear in roughly one in seven
viewings of the tape
this cloaked figure was designated
scp-1981-1 and he became part of the
reoccurring imagery in the nightmares
that often followed a viewing of SCP in
1981. naturally despite containment and
preservation attempts the foundation was
aware that just like any normal tape
natural magnetic interference would
eventually degrade it Beyond use
attempts to copy the footage onto
another betamax tape failed to reproduce
the anomalous effects that's why the
foundation has painstakingly recorded
any video and audio they could via
standard commercial camcorder in one
particularly terrifying playback
scp-1981-1 took the president's place at
the podium staring directly into the
camera the words I see you appeared over
a black screen shortly after staff
members were ordered never to make an
attempt at communicating with the figure
and instead contact a level 4 Superior
if such an event occurs during a
playback again
the frightening and unfortunate effects
of scp-1981 would come to their logical
conclusion under the watchful eye of Dr
James Kyle Robinson managing archivist
of inert safe class objects and
anomalous items at site 73. he was
contacted by special agent Arnold
Rodriguez and special agent Ethan Tate
members of the Secret Service with a
duty to protect President Reagan word
had gotten to Reagan that there was an
anomalous artifact in the possession of
the foundation that directly pertained
to him and he wanted to see it
Dr Robinson obtained files and
transcripts pertaining to scp-1981 and
handed them over to the agents but
refused to allow President Reagan to see
the tape directly without approval from
o5 command the Reagan and the Agents
were persistent eventually o5 command
ordered a private screening of the tape
for President Reagan at the Sanford
chemical processing plant a front
business owned and operated by the
foundation for amnestic production Dr
Robinson offered President Reagan the
use of amnestics after the session
completed but Reagan declined the
screening took place in conference room
B and the tape was replayed three times
it was on the third playback that things
took an interesting turn as the
mutilated Reagan on the screen began to
rant about drinking the blood of a child
from the skull of Vladimir Putin Reagan
began to silently mouth along the words
as though he remembered them he spoke
about beings known as the Destroyers and
potential apocalyptic events to come
after the screening Reagan once again
refused the offer of amnestics and
departed
it seemed as though all was well until a
violent break-in at the Sanford chemical
processing plant that left a night guard
dead
a large number of amnestics had been
stolen during the break-in and security
footage showed that agent Tate and
Rodriguez had been responsible the two
agents were tracked down and traced to
the residents of Ronald Reagan where the
foundation Came Upon a disturbing site
the agents had pillaged large quantities
of Class A and B and mistakes and
supplied them to President Reagan who at
some point after observing scp-1981 had
been driven into a dangerous Madness the
two agents wanted to cure him before he
caused harm to himself or others but
their bungling had come with severe
consequences misapplying such a high
quantity of amnestics had essentially
destroyed Reagan's mind and while the
foundation was able to stabilize his
condition his impaired memory and
cognitive function would leave him
unable to care for himself independently
in order to cover up for this Grievous
mistake a cover story was concocted
about Reagan falling victim to
Alzheimer's and facing severe cognitive
decline as a result
both agents tayden Rodriguez were fired
for their actions had their memories
wiped by the foundation and were
assigned new identities Dr Robinson for
his part in the disaster had to face a
foundation Ethics Committee disciplinary
hearing
while scp-1981 continues to be
classified as safe due to its
unlikeliness to ever breach containment
when you consider the havoc and Rod on
the mind of its singular Target safe is
hardly the word that comes to mind it's
enough to make you wonder what other
tapes are lurking out there just waiting
to be found it all started with a
panicked phone call a local landlady who
owned a downtown tenement building had
called the police in hysterics something
horrifying had happened to one of her
tenants she couldn't possibly explain
the one detail she was able to
articulate was that his room looked like
a rainforest a police response team was
on the case in no time they drove down
to the tenement building met the crying
landlady out the door and found their
way to the room that caused all this
confusion when they'd opened the door
they saw with horror that she was right
trees plants fungi and even insects and
animals were all over the room it was
teeming with life the floor on fala in
this room didn't look like anything else
on Earth and given the anomalous nature
of what had happened here it's extremely
possible they were right the tenant a
university Professor who'd recently gone
on an anthropological expedition to the
Amazon rainforest was nowhere to be seen
but one of the officers spotted a grim
clue for what may have happened to him a
large colony of anomalous mold was
quickly growing on the far wall the
officer swore was a trek of the mind at
first but he was wrong a human skull was
sinking into the tissue of the mold and
to make matters worse whipping tendrils
began to Slither from the empty eye
sockets reaching for the new meat
thankfully for everyone who was still
alive at this point the SCP Foundation
swooped in and took over the situation
with the help of a mobile task force and
some containment Specialists the
landlady the cops and the other
residents of the building were given
amnestics and relocated the building was
purchased by the foundation and
condemned while they searched the
anomalous room for the source of this
unchecked biological growth and they
found their answer in a most unlikely
form an unmarked cassette tape still
inside the player when they arrived the
recording on this cassette tape came to
be known as
scp-407 it may be unassuming when
compared to a mortal misanthropic lizard
monsters and multi-dimensional Chaos
Gods but the tape in that room if it
ever fell into the wrong hands could
cause a mass ecological catastrophe that
would inevitably Bloom into a dreaded XK
Class end of the world scenario so first
things first what is actually on this
tape thanks to brief samples heard and
tests with d-class Personnel the
foundation was able to discover that it
was an approximately 28 minute long
recording of a song it's performed in an
unknown language
and appears to be sung acapella Style by
a group of unknown individuals fearing
potential degradation of the cassette
the foundation backed it up as an
audiophile in the site-19 computer
database those who've been able to
listen to the song during testing have
had an overwhelmingly positive emotional
response describing it as soothing
glorious and beautiful and for the first
minute of its run time the songs
anomalous effect really live up to this
reputation when the song is played it
massively accelerates cell growth within
its auditory range its potency is
increased by the volume and the length
it's allowed to play it's important to
note that plugging or covering your ears
won't make any difference the area of
effect seems to be defined by how far
the sound vibrations travel and whether
you're actually able to hear it is
irrelevant but if you're only listening
for a minute or less you'll be glad to
feel the anomalous effect of being
within
scp-407's auditory range during this
specific period of time it's been shown
to be a kind of miracle cure to almost
all physical maladies with the exception
of cancer thanks to the cell-growing and
rejuvenating properties of the song the
foundation discovered that 407 was an
effective treatment for Alzheimer's
disease Crohn's disease brain and spinal
cord injuries and normally fatal
infections or wounds amongst other
maladies it was like a version of
scp-500 the pills that can cure
everything but one that would never run
out so if it's such an effective healer
why wasn't it more widely employed by
the foundation because of what happens
if you keep listening if the song was
played for two to three minutes the
subject would begin to experience
unnecessary and unchecked cell growth
particularly on the skin the result
would mostly be benign tumors and
calcium and fat deposits which though
sometimes painful and disfiguring are
not life-threatening thing at minute 4
single-celled organisms in the auditory
vicinity of the song begin to experience
accelerated mitosis also known as cell
division this results in bacterial and
fungal growth that become extremely
dangerous for anyone and anything
exposed and Beyond minute five things
become truly monstrous the foundation
only ever conducted two tests wherein
the song was fully played these tests
presented such a huge danger that
further testing of 407 was forbidden
without explicit permission from a
member of o5 command the first test
involved a female member of d-class
Personnel in a soundproofed but
unsterilized testing chamber as expected
she was initially delighted by the music
it cured her injured knee and brought
her back to a state of Peak Physical
Fitness but this didn't last for long
she soon began to report intense
dizziness and stomach pain resulting in
severe sickness at this point anomalous
plant growth began in the core corners
of the testing chamber it seemed as
though a whole ecosystem was coming to
life and evolving at an impossibly fast
raid in the chamber over the next few
minutes the d-class experienced a
nightmarish physical transformation her
skin became a thick calloused Mass she
soon evolved further into a thick
immobile blob of pure flesh
unrecognizable as anything human while
the chamber around her was becoming a
lush rainforest of alien plants these
plants grew around and eventually on her
until there was nothing left shortly
after all the plants died and decomposed
giving away to a huge mound of anomalous
mold devouring the resulting mulch the
mold itself began to evolve growing
Largemouth and hand-like structures that
it used to feed itself on the
surrounding flora and fauna as he began
to grow back when the song ended the
foundation brought the test to a close
sterilized the room and collected some
samples for later there was no nothing
left of the original d-class subject the
second test wasn't any nicer while at
first the subject this time a male
member of d-class personnel appeared to
become more youthful and even gain an
inch of height as the minutes passed he
began to experience extreme discomfort
he soon began to vomit with the vomit
quickly blooming into plants plant
shoots also began to quickly spring out
of his eyes and mouth until his entire
body was destroyed by what appeared to
be a banana tree suddenly growing out of
it once again the testing chamber became
a whole ecosystem this one filled with
unique never before seen mammals however
it all came to an end when the room was
taken over by a fast-growing parasitic
fungus that consumed everything else
with its spores and fungal stalks and it
looked like it was breathing there was
something concerning about both of these
tests beyond the obvious physical horror
of Watching Death by unchecked cell
growth what was this mysterious fungus
that kept appearing and seemed to take
over everything it touched in the end
the foundation tested the samples it
collected rigorously and it came to a
surprising conclusion they'd actually
encountered this same fungus before but
not in this Dimension
scp-507 is a man with Dimension hopping
abilities the one problem is he can't
control where and when he hops as a
result he's been stuck in a number of
scary alternate Dimensions but one
seemed eerily similar to what the
foundation was encountering with
scp-407 in one dimension he briefly
hopped into 507 encountered an abandoned
version of sight 19 strewn with corpses
covered in that same breathing mold he
was horrified but decided to inspect
further hoping to find his way out of
the facility and discover some answers
about what happened here however when he
found his way out what he discovered
didn't comfort him the entire our world
seemed to be covered by the same mold
there was nothing left it consumed
everything thanks to Foundation tests
both molds were found to be similar to
the cordyceps fungi a kind of dangerous
parasitic mold except this one appeared
to be a far more evolved and even more
deadly version of the fungus What could
this mean what was the origin of this
anomalous song Would it and the fungus
it seems to inspire someday destroy the
world as we know it and kill us all
we'll never actually know the answer to
any of this and it's thanks to an
extremely unlikely Ally A Person of
Interest nicknamed LS a prominent member
of the Serpent's hand this enigmatic
figure had previously come into
possession of
scp-268 a hat that made them almost
impossible to detect with the help of
this hat LS breached site 19 and an
incident that was later dubbed security
breach incident x-23 wallets believed
that LS mainly broke into the facility
to make the use of scp-914 they
performed a curious action along the way
they hacked into the foundation database
and deleted all traces of
scp-407 effectively neutralizing it in a
note left by LS they said you'll thank
me for deleting what you call 407. why
would a member of the Serpent's hand a
group of interest that is often militant
in their anti-neutralization stance
neutralize and SCP themselves the answer
to this lays and who exactly LS is this
mysterious figure isn't technically one
person they're a group of the same
person namely a woman named Alison Chao
from a number of different dimensions
they meet in The Wanderers Library the
headquarters of the Serpent's hand that
exists between Dimensions to coordinate
their missions why does this matter in
regards to scp-407 because the nature of
Ls allows them to know what's going on
in a huge number of Dimensions at once
this means much like the brief Glimpse
given by scp-507 LS likely knows about
another Universe where 407 and its
horrific mold have already caused an XK
class scenario and destroyed the world
and if it happened there due to poor
biological containment measures or 407
falling into the wrong hands it could
happen here too unless of course someone
stepped in and dealt with the problem
personally and while the foundation's
policy is typically to contain rather
than neutralize the anomalies they find
we have to admit we're probably with the
Serpent's hand on this one some songs as
it turns out are just better left
unplayed you're sitting in the middle of
a cheering crowd the arena around you is
electric fans hollering from their seats
as they watch the basketball game every
Point scored every shot missed and every
skillful pass of the ball sends waves of
excitement over everyone in the audience
Applause shouts and chants fill the air
it distracts you for a moment you find
yourself swept up in the energy of the
game but slowly surely a nagging feeling
creeps up on you as your eyes follow the
ball that feeling turns to a sickening
realization as one of the players jumps
and dunks the basketball scoring another
two points you notice the look on his
face the same look on the faces of all
the other players on the court a solemn
hopeless expression it's the same look
of Silent despair worn by all the
spectators around you then you remember
you've watched this exact game of
basketball before many many times before
and that is when you feel the same
hopeless expression appear on your own
face realizing just how long you have
been here watching this game over and
over over reminded that you will never
ever leave this Arena welcome to
scp-1733 to the untrained eye
scp-1733 seems to be a completely
harmless item stored in a digital video
recorder it is kept securely in the
dusty depths of the SCP foundation's
video archives if any researcher is
given permission to study scp-1733 they
will find it to be an ordinary VHS tape
but what about the contents of said tape
does it contain a bizarre disconnected
series of black and white video clips
that when viewed only give the Watchers
seven days before the spirit of a
drowned girl comes crawling out of their
TV screen to kill them well not exactly
but we're sure that if such a tape
exists the foundation probably has it
under lock and key too the footage on
scp-1733 is as seemingly banal as the
ordinary VHS tape itself when played the
viewer will witness a TV broadcast of a
basketball game specifically the
2010-2011 NBA season opener broadcast on
television and captured on tape by an
unknown civilian the game took place on
the 26th of October 2010 in the TD
Garden arena in Boston Massachusetts a
game where the hometown Boston Celtics
took on the Miami Heat by now perhaps
you're wondering what is so special
about this particular game and why the
SCP Foundation would be so interested in
keeping a VHS recording of it so secure
is one of the o5 councils secretly a
Celtics fan while that's impossible to
say for sure while we do know for
certain is that scp-1733 is far more
than just a harmless recording of a
basketball game the SCP Foundation First
caught wind of
scp-1733's existence the day after the
game on October 27th a Boston native
that had watched and recorded the game
made comments on social media about a
technical foul that the game's referee
had failed to pick up on according to
this individual during the third quarter
an instance of unsportsmanlike conduct
took place between Ray Allen and Chris
Bosh the person making these claims was
quickly ridiculed by commenters on the
same thread but then this person
uploaded a clip of this foul from the
footage they had recorded the other
commenters were dumbfounded during the
original broadcast that foul had never
happened but the recording showed it
clear as day the footage was quickly
expunged and all traces of the clip
removed from the Internet by Personnel
acting on behalf of the SCP Foundation
any that had viewed the video on
Facebook or been a part of the comments
debating this previously non-existent
foul were Tracked Down via their IP
addresses all of them including the
owner of the tape were given amnestics
to wipe their memories of the supposed
infraction an scp-1733 was returned to
the foundation for further analysis
researchers at the foundation were
determined to understand the anomalous
nature of
scp-1733 and why the footage contained
on this particular VHS tape was so
different from the basketball game's
original broadcast at first the
differences in the game seem to be only
slight changes from the one that
actually aired on TV a different foul
here a small Point difference there
while the recording of the game
contained on scp-1733 was slightly
different from the real-life game
perhaps even more interesting was that
these differences changed with repeat
viewings researchers wouldn't observe
the same differences every time they
watched scp-1733 but would instead spot
something different that had been
changed each time they restarted the
tame and as they continued to watch and
re-watch
scp-1733's footage the true horror of
the video's anomalous properties became
more and more apparent as the footage
recorded on scp-1733 began to diverge
more and more from the original Brown
podcast researchers shifted their
attention away from the basketball game
itself and on to the people watching it
just like the specifics of the game
itself the fans in the arena seem to
also change with every re-watch of the
tank and even stranger the people in the
crowd seem to not only be aware of their
existence within the footage but also
retain memories of every previous
replayed Vision each time the
researchers had watched scp-1733 the
audience trapped within had gained more
and more cognizance every man woman and
child in the audience of that basketball
game began remembering that they had
seen multiple variations of the same
game over and over again this first
became apparent to Foundation
researchers when the game's commentators
two presenters named Mike and Tommy
began to comment on a strange sense of
deja vu they were experiencing as they
watched the Boston Celtics and Miami
Heat play both seemed to share Notions
that the game they were witnessing was
strangely familiar and in later replays
of the tape these two commentator
personalities were able to recall the
events of the game with perfect Vivid
accuracy while they never addressed the
viewer directly this cumulative effect
seems to have extended to every person
that was present within the arena at the
time that the original broadcast was
recorded everyone from the commentators
to the coaches the players to the
patrons all remember the diverging
versions of the basketball game but seem
to have no awareness that they are
trapped inside a recording on a VHS tape
it should be noted that it is still
unclear whether the entities are real
people or digital copies that solely
reside on the tape every individual
shown to be inside TD Garden on the 26th
of October 2010 seems to be identical to
their counterparts in the real world
each of the basketball players on both
the Boston Celtics and Miami Heat teams
have the exact same level of talent as
they do in reality and their individual
man aneurysms are perfectly recreated in
the scp-1733 footage and the same is
true of the fans in the audience each
one appearing to be in every conceivable
way a living human being but the most
unnerving aspect of scp-1733 was found
when the foundation agents were tasked
with tracking down members of the
audience who were seen on the tape and
they found nothing unlike the players
and coaches who can quite easily be
found in our world with many of them
still playing or involved with
professional basketball Personnel were
unable to find a single trace of any of
the people from the audience not one
clue as to their current whereabouts or
status it is unclear how but it appears
that everyone shown on
scp-1733 especially those watching the
game unfold from the stands is a person
trapped in digital form stuck watching
variations of the same match on Loop
researchers at the SCP Foundation who
were studying scp-1733 initially
theorized that the tape had been
designed to display an infinite variety
of different game outcomes given that
the tactics utilized by the players were
different with each playback of scp-1733
this seemed to be the case that the tape
was showing a what if scenario each time
the tape was rewound and played from the
start but the scenario wasn't resetting
each time it was clear that they were
learning by the 34th replay of the
footage the Boston Celtics and Miami
Heat were so in tune with the opposing
team's Playbook that both sides players
were able to perfectly and precisely
counter their opponent's moves and kept
the score at 0-0 for much of the game at
this stage in the foundation's research
the players on the scp-1733 tape had not
yet become fully aware that they had
played the same game already in earlier
playbacks but it is possible that weak
memories of the earlier versions of the
same match manifested as instinctive
ways players could counter the moves of
their rival team however by the time
Foundation researchers had replayed the
scp-1733 footage 45 times the players
their coaches and fans watching the game
had become aware of what was happening
to them it was at this point that the
digital recording from TD Garden changed
dramatically realizing that they'd been
playing the same game of basketball over
and over the players refused to
participate any longer everyone in the
audience began to attempt to escape from
the tape where they'd been unknowingly
imprisoned but not a single one of the
stadium stores would budge and neither
the fans nor the players seemed to be
able to leave through any other exit out
of TD Garden over the following
playbacks of the scp-1733 videotape
attempts at Escape grew increasingly
daring in one playback a full-scale riot
broke out in another makeshift
explosives were built and used by those
trapped to try and blast their way to
Freedom as as their cognition grew when
they began to remember friends and
family from outside the videotape the
crowd trapped an scp-1733 grew even more
desperate players and their coaches
retired to locker rooms withdrawing from
the crowd for a Time the rest of the
people in the footage began to form
factions amongst themselves one of the
more prominent calling themselves the
faith Keepers these individuals voiced
their belief that they had been confined
to TD Garden as some form of spiritual
punishment as a result of the
consumerism that is Rife in a
post-industrial society the faith
Keepers began burning offerings in the
center of the basketball court phones
wallets car keys anything that reminded
them of the modern world over the
subsequent playbacks of scp-1733 the
faith Keepers grew in their numbers
indoctrinating more of the crowd into
their movement those still trying to
escape from the stadium were causing
more damage to themselves than their
enclosure with three men caught in the
blast of another crude bomb placed on an
exit door unfortunately for them the
door barely showed a scratch in the
aftermath of the detonation as
Foundation researchers continued
replaying the tape those trapped with an
scp-1733 descended into depraved acts
and incidences of violence became
rampant some even attempted to take
their own lives and acts of desperation
jumping from balconies in the hopes of
ending the loop those that had joined
the growing ranks of the faith Keepers
did not engage in such Behavior instead
creating makeshift curtains to separate
themselves from the breakdown that was
taking place among the others trapped
within the
scp-1733 tank at some point beyond the
112th playback of the videotape the
faith Keepers marched off scream and
brought the basketball teams back out
onto the main Court they then began a
ritualistic sacrifice disemboweling the
professional athletes for their fellow
prisoners to see this had no noticeable
effect with the recording of the game
resetting as it had done in earlier
re-watches in a later playback the faith
Keepers then began to call for all the
children in the stadium to be sacrificed
in the same way testing on scp-1733 was
finally suspended indefinitely after
this point and as far as we know the
crowd remains trapped inside the
anomalous recording of this particular
Celtics Heat basketball game Foundation
researchers have been unable to produce
the same anomalous effects as those of
scp-1733 even when using the DVR that
originally produced the recording the
digital video recorder itself does not
seem to imprint the same properties onto
other VHS tapes making
scp-1733 and isolated anomaly however
the next time you find yourself in a
basketball game it might be worth asking
yourself have I seen this game before do
you like scary movies if you're a fan of
horror they're probably been quite a few
times where you found yourself yelling
at the movie screen don't go up to the
attic don't split up don't check out the
noise in the basement run out the front
door you know the characters can't hear
you but when the story is engaging
enough to make you care about their
well-being you can't help but try and
give them a hand after all you'd want
someone to save you from a machete
wielding Maniac stalking through a
summer camp you took up your new
counselor job at if someone was watching
you hide in the closet listening for a
masked Killer's footsteps with a kitchen
knife in your hand you'd want them to
give you a heads up when the killer was
getting ready to chop through the door
with an ax of course the characters in
your favorite movies never listen
because you know that's how movies work
but in 1985 a young man returned to VHS
tape entitled Return of the suburb
slasher to his local video store with a
peculiar complaint the main character of
the movie stopped mid-action to look at
the camera and beg for his hell the
video store clerk laughed him off and
refused to give him a refund though he
did eventually give in and offer store
credit after the man began to cry he
decided to take the tape home and watch
it just to see what all the fuss was
about after all he'd never seen someone
cry at a horror movie like that so he
sat down on his favorite beanbag chair
pushed the tape into the VCR and press
play apparently his shell-shocked
customer had at least remembered to be
kind and Rewind the movie told the story
of Heather Campbell a young woman
planning to host a party at her family's
home in a classic Suburban cul-de-sac
while her parents were out of town an
equally classic slasher fashion this
party would take place on the 10th
anniversary of a series of grisly
murders in the same neighborhood
committed by the mysterious suburb
slasher as the party kicks off with loud
music teenage debauchery and lots of
drinking out of red plastic cups the
killer appears to pick off the group of
friends one by one like other classic
your victims your Michaels and your
jasons the suburb slasher also covers
their face wearing a black burlap sack
over their head that masks all
identifiable features the first 90
minutes of the movie were fun but basic
a canoodling couple gets decapitated
here an unnecessary shower scene is cut
short by stabbing there the sort of
thing you'd expect but at about 97
minutes in something impossible happened
Heather walked into the living room
finding her friend's dead body strewn
across it and let out a scream that
measured up to the best in the genre the
teen scream Queen then began to run as
the killer appeared to chase her she
made her way into the basement of the
House locked the door behind her then
she turned to the camera Tears In Her
Eyes shirts spattered with blood and
said hey mister I don't know you and I
don't know why you've just sat there
watching this without doing nothing but
please I'm begging you help me out here
what can I do to survive this at first
the clerk thought he was under the
influence of some mind-altering
substance but the only things in his
system were popcorn and store brand soda
now this was really happening he stared
open mouth at the screen where Heather
watched him expectantly he was too
stunned to speak after a moment of
silence Heather's side dejectedly
shaking her head and turned back towards
the stairs she slowly walked back to the
basement door unlocked it and pulled it
open there the killer was waiting with
his expressionless burlap mask the
clerk's eyes widened and he cried out no
but it was too late the film suddenly
cut to Black and with a whirring sound
the VCR spat the tape back out the clerk
sat there staring at the tape what could
he do with it should he make a copy send
it to someone else and pass the curse
along should he try to watch it again he
wasn't sure he could bear to see Heather
looking at him with those same pleading
eyes then he remembered an ad he had
seen in the back of his favorite comic
book seeing something you can explain a
brush with the unknown keeping you up at
night we're looking for stories of the
strange and unusual
write to us now maybe they could do
something he couldn't he put the take
back into its cover placed it in an
envelope and mailed it off the next day
a few days later the package reached its
intended recipient an undercover branch
of the SCP Foundation tracking anomalous
activity via a series of ads in comic
books and video stores to tap into one
of the most underutilized resource in
the world nerds the tape was designated
scp-5733 and Heather and the mass killer
were designated
scp-5733-2 and
scp-5733-1 respectively after an initial
viewing confirmed its anomalous
properties a research team headed by Dr
Carpenter began to perform a series of
tests testing was open to all Foundation
employees subject to approval by Dr
Carpenter approved Personnel would be
placed in a site-73 multi-purpose room
with a VHS player and a television the
staff member would then watch the movie
and attempt to engage with Heather and
help her Escape for the first test
d-class 1973 was selected when Heather
turned to the camera and asked for help
he asked if she had a car when she
confirmed that yes she did he instructed
her to sneak back upstairs find her car
keys leave through the back door and
drive as fast and as far away as
possible she successfully retrieved the
car keys but when she reached the car
she saw that the tires had been slashed
Heather began to panic the 1973 talked
her through it telling her to smash the
window of a neighbor's car and unlock
the door she complied in 1973 instructed
her on how to hotwire the vehicle the
car started and with a triumphant laugh
she sped out of the cul-de-sac just as
her car began to pull away the killer
emerged from the back seat wielding a
kitchen knife Heather screamed and the
tape cut to Black for the next test
d-class 1944 was selected he began by
telling Heather to find her father's
shotgun seen earlier in the film and
used it to take out the killer before
they could get to her she snuck up to
her parents room and found the gun done
only for the killer to appear in the
doorway behind her she aimed the gun and
fired but nothing happened the killer
opened their hand dropping the shotgun
shells on the floor she was close but
the killer was one step ahead she
screamed as they approached with a knife
and again the tape cut to Black after
several tests were conducted with
d-class subjects and no adverse effects
were reported aside from the obvious
trauma of failing to save Heather's life
testing was opened up to all Foundation
staff assistant researcher felissa Baker
volunteered she believed her extensive
knowledge of the slasher genre would
give her the tools to help Heather
strategize after speaking with Heather
about her skills which mainly included
party planning and babysitting Felicia
determined that Heather should seek
outside help with felic's help Heather
made her way out of the house and over
to the home of her next-door neighbor Mr
Loomis when she got there the door was
open and the lights were off it didn't
look great but she didn't really have
much of a choice but to go inside she
made her way to the bedroom where Mr
Loomis and his wife were lying in bed
she tried to wake him but the camera
zoomed in to reveal his throat had been
slashed the shape in the bed next to him
Sat up and was not in fact his wife but
the suburb slasher instead has the
figure raised their Signature Kitchen
knife the screen went to Black
scp-5733 became a competition of sorts
among Foundation staff each volunteer
proposing their knowledge would help
them get heather to safety assistant
researcher Nick younglin daskowitz
proposed telling Heather to call for
help giving her a secret phone number
for the SCP Foundation Circa 1983 the
time in which the movie was set however
when Heather reached the phone it had
been destroyed smashed to Pieces next to
it was a note written in blood that said
the only foundation here is fear then
the killer appeared behind Heather and
the tape went to Black somehow the
killer knew about the SCP Foundation
perhaps in a manner of of speaking the
call was coming from inside the house
next field agent Malcolm Pleasants and
Donald McDowell were selected due to
their extensive knowledge of
hand-to-hand combat they attempted to
teach other various fighting and
self-defense techniques while she
survived on the limited supplies
available in the basement she eventually
left the basement and when the killer
appeared began to fight them after 23
minutes of combat she knocked the
slasher to the floor and grabbed the
Candlestick to finish them off as the
agents watching began to celebrate a
second version of the Suburban slasher
appeared behind her lunging forward just
before the new killer made contact the
tape cut to Black during this test the
slasher seemed more Adept at combat than
it had been before as though it could
hear the advice being given to Heather
with other techniques failing field
agent Tilda Joan Bennett was brought in
for a test selected due to her expertise
in thamaturgy she instructed Heather on
basic offensive and defensive thamaturgy
before guiding her out of the house and
into the front yard when the slasher
appeared brandishing their knife Heather
was able to sign a protective glyph and
defend against the knife's blow she
followed this with a wind spell that
pushed the killer further away Heather
began to run down the driveway making a
break for survival when the slasher
suddenly performed a free spell that
rendered her unable to move Heather's
wide panicked eyes stared down the
barrel of the camera in a Silent Scream
as the killer approached her recovered
the knife in hand before the tape went
to Black eventually Dr Carper
volunteered to conduct a test he
instructed his research team to prepare
a list of options for Heather's survival
divided into four categories what to
take from the basement where to go once
leaving the basement how to exit the
house and how to escape the cul-de-sac
he was not informed about any of these
options but rather had them printed out
and placed into plastic bowls on the day
of the test there were also three cards
created and placed face down reading
Face Body and legs when Heather
addressed Dr Carpenter he informed
warned her that he would be randomly
selecting instructions for her and asked
that she followed them exactly the first
slip of paper instructed Heather to grab
a pair of garden shears from the
basement and climb the stairs back into
the main house next she was told to go
upstairs to the bedroom then downstairs
into the dining room she complied and
there was no sign of the killer so far
third Dr Carpenter told Heather to run
back upstairs out of the bedroom window
onto the roof and then jumped down into
the garden then it was time for The Next
Step he told Heather to jump over the
fence into the neighbor's garden and run
down the street until she could find
help as Heather made her way down the
road the slasher broke through the front
door of her house but did not chase
after her Heather continued running down
the road for 20 minutes as the trees and
lights began to dwindle the surroundings
began to grow darker and darker until
they resembled a void Dr Carpenter
instructed her to keep walking she could
make out lights in houses in the
distance she ran toward the neighborhood
but stopped suddenly and began to panic
she was back in her own neighborhood in
front of her own house and the killer
was waiting for her as Heather demanded
to know what to do carpenter flipped
over one of the three cards it read face
and so he told Heather to attack the
Killer's face with the shears then the
Killer's legs then his body the killer
dodged her attack grabbed the shears and
pushed her to the ground as Heather
looked up at the killer his face could
be seen through the torn sack it was Dr
Carpenter Heather screamed and the tape
cut to Black talk about a third act
twist the movie itself did not create
the killer but somehow the viewer did
and it also made the killer more
creative after this incident all testing
on
scp-5733 was suspended and attempts to
help turn Heather from victim to
Survivor were halted searching for
answers the foundation looked into
Crystal Elms Productions the production
company listed on the videotapes cover
no record of the production company the
film or any of its casts could be found
several months after testing on scp-5733
was suspended another tape was found
because let's face it baby these days
you've gotta have a sequel the new tape
was titled the suburb slasher strikes
again and was purported to be produced
by Crystal Elms Productions in 1985. it
was designated
scp-6733 unlike its predecessor this
tape was only tested once a member of
d-class personnel was first shown
scp-5733 up until the point where it
becomes anomalous and was then shown as
CP 6733 he was left completely alone in
order to watch the contents of the tape
the following was what was on it Dr
Malcolm Baines entered the testing
chamber to find d1974 or Jaime sitting
across from the television set he
introduced himself and ran a series of
cognitive tests he asked Jamie what he
thought of the film and he said I was
pretty much your standard slasher film
there's a group of teens who just
graduated high school and go to a local
camping site by like to celebrate one of
the mentions that's near the site where
the killer the slasher was shot dead by
police a year prior after a rampage Dr
Baines clarified asking if this was a
reference to the first film Jaime
continued it's not really clear they all
think it's a joke apart from the main
girl she said her dad's a police officer
and she's seen video evidence of the
attack no one references any of the
characters from the first film though
and they don't show up in this one
either the slasher is the only constant
according to Jaime the main events of
the film revolved around a Lakeside
camping trip and quickly began to go
wrong Dr Baines inquired about the
nature of the slasher's kills and Jaime
elaborated he's still got a kitchen
knife same weapon as the first film so
he stabs a lot of them it's pretty Gory
for the time it was made he slashes up
someone's face then the nerdy guy gets
stabbed through the eye that one's
pretty good the camera gets sprayed with
blood one of the teens gets his head
crushed wide open Dr Baines asked Jamie
how the scenes made him feel he
responded like there's some good jump
scares and the tension's Fairly high at
points but that's a little dated I've
seen scarier but I've also seen worse
Horrors only one part of the film stood
out to him he described it so the girl
and her best friend the one that's been
looking out for her this whole time
entered into a Cellar the slasher creeps
up from behind and grabs the friend
tears his head clean off his neck the
slasher then chases the other teen to
the other side of the lake he's
advancing on her the camera set on the
water of the lake it's a wide shot
you've got the lake water line parallel
to the top and bottom of the shot so it
splits the screen horizontally she's
fallen over crawling away from him as he
advances on her the camera Zooms in
slowly though it takes its time and he
does too there's music at the start of
the scene like deep dark synths the stop
says the camera moves closer though I
forgot to say it's a long scene longer
than five minutes maybe it was ten I
don't know it felt longer than 10. so
slasher's approaching her we're the
viewers approaching the shore then the
music stops and it's just his footsteps
and her pleading and she's pleading man
she's there's these big inhales of
breath stifled by the mucus running out
of her nose and she's babbling but it
gets to the point she's not even saying
words just making noise has Jamie
continued he began to grow increasingly
distressed the camera's real close to
the shore now and the slasher stops
he turns his head and looks straight at
the camera you can't see his eyes but
you know he's looking straight at you
and he just stands there staring
eventually the girl crawls out of the
frame or the camera zooms past her I
can't remember which it just keeps
zooming in on his face or his face
should be under the hood the girl keeps
screaming off camera and then there's
this guttural ripping noise and the
screaming stops it just stops but the
camera keeps moving you can see the
individual droplets of blood splashed
across him you can see the Fabrics that
make up his hood his face soon takes up
the entire shot and then black no
credits or nothing the tape just cuts to
Black and was pushed out of the player
Dr Baines pushed a bit asking if there
was anything anomalous he could be
forgetting then Jaime thought of
something the girl her friends all of
them I I don't think they had names
Jamie became increasingly disturbed by
the film over time calling Dr Baines
into his dormitory to ask him if they
had shown him a snuff film after falling
asleep he had a vivid dream of the lake
crawling alongside it recalling the
deaths of his friends at the hand of a
masked killer when he woke up he saw a
Shadow outside the window of his room it
stood there silent and unmoving all
night it only vanished when the sun came
up the next night surveillance caught
the image of a humanoid shape running
through the forest but the guards found
no trace of it Dr Baines returned to
Jamie's cell to find him deeply
distressed he repeated over and over
that the slasher was coming for him Dr
Baines dismissed this concern once Jaime
was alone he stared into the mirror as
the temperature began to drop you're
here aren't you he said a gloved hand
punctured through the mirror spraying
glass everywhere on the other side there
he was the suburb slasher Jaime fled his
dormitory and ran for his life as the
slasher followed him security officer
Lauren confronted the slasher but they
lifted him up by the neck and stabbed
The Familiar kitchen knife through his
head Jaime continued to make his way
through the facility the slasher
following and leaving a trail of
Destruction and bodies in his wake then
he reached Dr Baines who was confused by
his behavior Dr Baines insisted that he
needed to get to the basement but
terrified Jaime resisted him the two men
scuffled and Jamie shoved Dr Bane's hard
sending him careening into the wall a
lighting rig fell from the ceiling
landing on Dr Baines several strangers
ran into the room calling for a medic on
set and asking for production and
lighting to come back and reset
everything off-screen a director yelled
cut the slasher's face appeared taking
up the entirety of the camera and the
tape cut to Black this version of the
tape's events was created after the tape
was watched by D 1888 in a testing
session with Dr Carpenter there has
never been a Dr Baines in the SCP
foundation's employee somehow this
second tape creates a localized
destabilization of RAM it is unknown how
many times it has actually been tested
so be careful what horror rentals you
decide to watch you might just find
yourself in the middle of the action and
no matter what you think you know about
surviving a slasher film there will be
no Escape you can run but you certainly
can't hide okay guys so to wrap this
video up I really don't think this
cursed episode of this show was real
it's obviously just a really good scary
fan animation and the fact that the
creators behind it didn't come out and
claim ownership of it sooner allowing it
to be reposted and re-uploaded so many
times is really what got people thinking
was legit that being said it's still a
good attempt at what a cursed Lost
episode would look like so shout out to
those animators man anyway I've been the
goat hellholder 98 be sure to like this
video subscribe to my channel down below
and hey if you know about any more lost
media you want me to cover leave it in
the comments I'll check it out and be
sure to follow my socials at
hellholder98 I go live most days and
post updates about new videos on my
story so go check it out alright until
then I'll see you somewhere down the
line the moment his finger pushed the
button to stop the camera recording the
practiced false smile dropped from
Holden's face it was hard not to feel
down after he'd finished filming a new
video not thanks to any post-creativity
slump but the more depressing knowledge
of just how much of an uphill battle
this whole thing was it felt like
yesterday when Holden had first gotten
into the creepier side of the internet
he never ventured into anything illicit
or outright illegal mind you but there
was a distinct corner of the web that
had pulled him in when he was still at
school and just starting to spend more
time online this part of the internet
was filled with scary stories that were
mostly fake or made up for likes but
that could have been real there were
unsettling animations short clips that
were hand drawn to give people the
creeps and keep them up at night not to
mention a whole Archive of Public Safety
announcement videos terrifying workplace
and road safety warnings that used to be
broadcast on TV and were as petrifying
than the most acclaimed horror movies
speaking of things that were broadcast
to TV that had gradually become Holden's
specialty one of his friends had sent
him the link to a fictional account of
someone who had supposedly uncovered an
unaired episode of a Saturday morning
kids cartoon or so this person claimed
anyway they went on to describe bizarre
imagery so intense and terrifying that
it was unbefitting of a show for
children then the person who made the
original post explained how they got
into contact with the show's creators
via email to ask them about this cursed
episode The showrunner responded stating
that the episode the poster had
allegedly seen didn't even exist to
Holden it didn't matter if the story was
real or not that wasn't the point what
was far more important was that it felt
real to him it was plausible even
possible that there were pieces of media
out there in the world that had never
seen the light of day episodes of TV
shows or in entire movies that were so
wild and out there that they could have
been banned and buried long before the
dawn of the internet wherein there was a
record of everything and nothing was
ever really lost the idea of uncovering
those lost pieces of media became
Holden's primary hobby he'd come home
from school throw his backpack onto his
bed and then sit in front of his
computer for hours without even changing
out of the clothes he had been wearing
all day in class but all the time he
spent trawling through form threads
following and messaging collectors on
social media listening to theories and
coming up with his own eventually it
began to encroach on other things much
to his mom's disappointment Holden's
grades took a rapid decline it wasn't
long before he was failing his classes
bad enough to not make the cut to
continue on at school but as much as it
upset his mother Holden really didn't
mind he was already thinking Way Beyond
high school and he knew he didn't need
grades to be able to do the one thing he
wanted to do with his life Holden set up
his own Channel with the plan to start
uploading videos under his new online
alter ego and before long hell holder 98
was born he centered his whole internet
Persona around lost media discussing
which popular rumors were true and which
were fictionalized for likes and clicks
it started out with a few discussion
videos where he would simply sit in his
bedroom a camcorder opposite to him as
he spoke but before long Holden was
adding more and more Flair to his
content learning how to edit on his
computer adding Clips or screenshots he
could find of supposed Lost TV episodes
to give his videos some credibility a
very necessary quality when trying to
determine if certain things were real or
not each video he finished he had
another two topics to a list of ideas he
kept planning to just perpetually churn
out content until he eventually had a
huge hit that went viral although the
one thing he didn't realize until it was
perhaps too late was that social media
success didn't happen overnight in fact
it didn't happen over many many nights
either no matter how often Holden
promoted his channel on his social media
profiles or how many new videos he
uploaded he couldn't seem to get any to
land well and get boosted by the
algorithm at least that's one of the
things he attributed the problem to he
pointed the finger of blame at anything
that he could one day it was that the
algorithm was suppressing his channel
and boosting others who had already got
more subscribers the next it might be
his slow internet connection had led to
one of his videos going live at a time
when the site had low traffic the one
possibility that Holden didn't stop to
consider was that maybe his genre of
content was too Niche but that the days
of the internet's interest in Lost media
had already peaked back when he was
still in high school nevertheless he
kept trying making content day in and
day out working under the assumption
that if he just made enough videos then
one day he was sure to blow up that
would be his big break his ultimate win
a video that did well enough to 100
thousands if not millions of views but
the more time he devoted to Hell holder
98 the only number that seemed to be at
all increasing was the number of videos
he had posted each one barely garnering
view figures that were above a single
digit to make matters worse getting help
with growing his online brand was next
to Impossible every now and then he
would post on forms asking for advice or
if anyone wanted to collaborate so he
could gain some exposure from creators
with bigger followings those posts were
often met with a slew of apathetic snide
responses or comments telling Holden 2
just quote make better content as if
that was solid specific advice on top of
that his mom had outright refused to
support her son's chosen career path
citing his failure at school as the main
reason speaking of any friends Holden
previously had at school had all moved
away in the years since going off to
pursue college and other higher
education some were even starting their
new and exciting professions the old
saying said it's Lonely at the Top but
hold and was just as lonely down at the
bottom posting his content in total
obscurity as if he was just shouting
into an empty void with no one around to
hear the few people Holden did still
consider his friends were all as
chronically online as he was most of
them fellow lost media collectors after
interacting with them in the common
threads of various forums a handful of
like-minded guys were as close as Holden
had to people actively supporting his
channel the collectors would usually
give him pointers or topics to discuss
in videos and contributing to the single
digit view count underneath his uploads
although to him it wasn't nearly enough
he didn't want just his friends to see
his videos he wanted an audience a fan
base of his own it was late the light of
the computer monitor Illuminating the
dark of Holden's bedroom hunched over
his desk he was clicking and dragging
clips into the timeline of a video
project trimming them down to make the
whole thing better paced snipping out
bad takes where he stumbled over his
words or spoke it was while editing that
Holden noticed another screen lighting
up on his desk accompanied by a
vibration his phone he reached for it
seeing a notification popped up on the
lock screen it was from gov one of the
Lost media collectors and it read dude
urgent found something that you can make
a video on hold inside it was late and
he was already focused on editing this
current video tonight if you got it
finished then he could go to sleep what
do you know about the deathly videotape
goeth asked in a second message before
Holden even had a chance to open it
first the what he replied bluntly before
sending another text saying can't this
wait until the morning I'm trying to
edit if you don't act fast it'll be gone
forever came the response only a second
later followed by a link lethargically
hold and tapped the hyperlink oath had
sent his phone opening up its browser
and displaying the web page it was a buy
and sell website one of those places
where people offloaded junk they didn't
want anymore to strangers for a bit of
extra cash the page in question showed a
few grainy photos taken on on a phone of
a small rectangular object in someone's
hand what is that Holden asked it's a
videotape bonehead both fired back
although they'd never met in person
Holden always got the sense his friend
was a little older than he was looking
back on the seller's ad it was for a
secondhand Sony color collection 60 to
90 minute mini DV videotape a type of
cassette used in a lot of old handheld
recording cameras so what holdenast in
another text look there have been rumors
for Aegis about something called The
Deathly videotape growth replied in a
series of Rapid Fire messages it used to
be all the rage on a lot of old lost
media forums the real nasty ones before
they got shut down supposedly there's a
recording on this tape of some kind of
live show except when you put in your
VCR and press play you see something
horrible nobody even knows if it's real
or just a legend how do you know this is
the same tape Holden queried by now he
had typed out the same link on his
computer and was looking at the for sale
page on the bigger screen while he
texted back and forth with both read the
item description he answered Holden's
eyes scan down the page finding a short
message from the seller to anyone
interested I'm giving this old Mini DV
tape away I don't know where I got it or
why I watched it but I wish I hadn't it
had ruined everything for me it's
impossible to enjoy anything else now
that I've seen what's on it let me make
this clear I am not selling this tape
I'm giving it away free of charge I hope
that getting rid of it will help sounds
ominous holding texted if you're so sure
if this is the deathly videotape then
why don't you get it keep reading growth
responded underneath the item
description was another note that the
seller had written please note I am
unable to leave my town at present nor
can I mail this tape to anyone even if
you pay postage collection only if
you're interested please contact me at
the following address below was an
address it was in Holden's Hometown only
a few streets away from where he and his
mom lived this could be it dude came
another slew of messages from gov you
buy this tape and make a video recording
then you might finally go viral but you
better be quick before someone goes and
picks it up thinking it's just an
ordinary tape Holden looks back at the
address double checking where it was at
most it'd take a quick walk there and
back he thought and if this tape was as
elusive as ghost said it was then owning
it would mean Holden would be the only
one who could make a video featuring it
after messaging the seller the night
before Holden found himself rushing
through his quiet neighborhood to the
address all night as he tried to sleep
he kept thinking of the video he was
going to make how he could finally put
him on the map and at long last bring
him the e-fame he'd been working towards
wrapping his knuckles against the front
door he was met by an older man who
stood on the other side he was walking
with a crutch with a few bruises and
stitched up cuts on his face the second
that Holden explained he was there for
the tape the man reached to an unseen
shelf just inside the door frame and
thrust the rectangular cassette into his
hands before shutting the door as
quickly as he could without it hitting
Holden Square in the face he stared at
the tape in his hands though through its
transparent green plastic case he could
see a hand scrawled note I know you'll
ignore me if I tell you not to watch
this it read so if you do then on your
own head be it having spent the rest of
the day looking up exactly what he'd
need to play such an old out modded
recording format and convert the footage
to digital so he could include it in his
video Holden had retrieved his mom's old
VHS player from the attic wiping the
thick layer of dust off of it it took a
while for him to get everything ready to
go not just finding the right adapters
and cables to hook the VCR up to his TV
as well as linking that to his computer
plus angling his camera right and making
sure the ring light he bought for
filming was putting enough focus on his
face after the substantial prep Holden
took a deep breath summoning up the faux
excitement and Stage smile before he hit
the record button on his camera what's
up guys it's hellholder98 here now today
I've got a real treat for you all so my
friend goth shout out to him told me
that a while ago there was talk about
something called the deathly videotape
we found a mini DV tape that we think
might be that very same tape so we're
gonna watch it and see if it's legit
dropping his Persona as his face turned
away from the camera Holden punched the
play button on the VHS player his eyes
glued to the TV screen as the camera's
lens was fixated on him okay nothing so
far he observed met with nothing but a
blank black screen suddenly after 12
seconds of nothing the playback started
instantly and Holden started relaying
what he was seeing on the tape to the
camera there was no sound either because
the recording on the videotape was
filmed that way or Holden hadn't
properly figured out how to hook it up
to the VHS the video itself showed a
recording of Sesame Street Live and for
the most part just seemed pretty
underwhelming characters were up on
stage their puppeteers managing to stay
out of sight as they entertained their
young audience after two and a half
minutes Holden was starting to feel like
he'd gone to all this effort over what
seemed to just be someone's old unwanted
home video just as he was considered
during turning off the camera and
throwing the videotape in the trash at
almost the three minute Mark something
weird started happening on the stage the
actor playing one of the bigger
characters seemed to be having some
trouble instantly trying to pull off his
cumbersome costume much to the distress
of the kids in the audience looking on
in horror but it wasn't just the
illusion that had been broken the actor
was trying to get out of his costume
because he was choking he dropped to his
knees on stage clawing at his own throat
before Finally Falling face down totally
still asphyxiated dead over the next
almost 20 seconds the same thing started
happening to another three of the
characters on stage all of them
violently choking while the children in
the audience screamed and cried silently
on the inaudible tape then at three and
a half minutes the video cut out Holden
was unsure how to react at first a
little creeped out only to be somewhat
bemused he played it down for the camera
remarking that the video seemed tame
compared to some of a more graphic fake
content he'd seen but the whole time
even after rapping recording sitting
awake all night to edit his reaction
video blurring out the parts that would
break the terms of service he had no
idea what he'd seen was actually real or
not finishing the final edit just as the
sun was coming up Holden hit upload and
crawled into bed while his video was
uploaded the buzz of a text message from
goath awoke him dude I told you this
video was going to make it big without
even replying Holden booted up his
computer and opened the page for his
newly uploaded video The View count was
already in the thousands and climbing
comments pouring in underneath mostly
from people debating whether or not the
contents of the tape had been faked
Holden punched the air and excitement
he'd finally done it but as the video
kept playing he heard a wretching sound
coming from the computer's speakers he
turned to look back at his earlier self
filmed only the night before except what
he was seeing play out on screen now
wasn't what he remembered happening last
night it couldn't have because the
Holden in that video was choking that
wasn't possible he was alive and
watching his own video right now but
somehow the footage was shown him dying
his Airway blocked face turning red then
blue was tears streamed down his cheeks
in the video hell holder 98 fell down
dead from asphyxiation and watching it
made Holden feel sick to make matters
worse none of the comments under the
video seemed to have witnessed the same
ending Holden even texts goeth to ask if
the same thing had happened but he
described the ending exactly as Holden
remembered filming it but afterwards it
didn't stop happening everything he
watched ended the same every clip online
every TV show every movie Holden
couldn't even read a book without some
characters fictional or otherwise
Keeling over and choking to death just
like the characters on the tape he
barely had time to acknowledge the hits
his reaction to the deathly videotape
we're getting he was too busy trying to
figure out why he couldn't stop seeing
people dying the exact same way even
himself self when he watched back his
old hellholder 98 videos reacting to the
deathly videotape garnered a respectable
3 million views but hellholder 98 never
uploaded again afterwards his channel
went silent remembered only as a one-hit
wonder until the video and the entire
Channel were taken down Holden was never
reported missing the foundation made
sure of that when they came by to
collect scp-583 and place the videotape
into containment hey do you have a
favorite reality show oh come on don't
lie everyone has one Dr clef loves some
American Ninja Warrior and I've got it
on good authority that Dr bright can't
get enough of the bachelor so how about
you huh do you obsessively follow the
Romantic highs and lows of Love island
or are you more of the type who likes to
curl up with a mug of hot cocoa and
enjoy a nice wholesome episode of The
Great British baking show do you ever
yell at the TV when the contestants on
Jeopardy just can't get the answer right
do you get a kick out of seeing what
crazy Collectibles will show up on this
week's episode of Pawn Stars if you
answered yes to any of these you're not
alone millions of people around the
world still tune in to all kinds of
reality TV personally I just can't get
enough of my favorite hidden camera show
laugh is fun what's that you've never
heard of laugh is fun no
oh boy you're really missing out if you
like reality TV you're going to love
laugh is fun laugh is fun also known as
scp-2030 isn't a show that you can watch
on TV instead it appears as the most
popular form of media distribution in
the current year today you can find it
on file sharing and streaming websites
but in the 2000s you could rent it from
the DVD kiosk at the mall and back in
the 90s it used to show up as
multi-taped sets in video rental stores
even though the SCP Foundation has only
been aware of lapis fun since 1993. it
has a recorded 38 Seasons as of 2014
meaning that it may have existed in some
form as far back as the 1970s if you
want to binge all 38 Seasons you might
also want to look it up under the names
laugh is life or in some countries laugh
is laugh and if you happen to be in a
country where laugh is laugh isn't
available you may want to try changing
your location using a VPN to one where
you can access it oh what's that you
don't have a VPN service well then I'm
glad you're here because before we go
any further I have a very important word
from our sponsor who just so happens to
be ignored VPN the preferred VPN service
of all the researchers here at SCP
explained sign up now at nordvpn.com
forward slash SCP explained nordvpn
isn't just a VPN it's truly the best VPN
available with a simple click you'll be
able to access content that might be
blocked just because of your location so
you'll never have to miss an episode of
your favorite anomalous television
programs but wait there's more much much
more what if you're right in the middle
of binge watching of season 31 when
suddenly your quality dips to looking
like a couple of blurry blocks or
fighting over an old shoebox never fear
because nordvpn encrypts all of your
traffic that means your internet service
provider can throttle your service and
slow down your streaming speed you
should never settle for less than the
highest quality pixels after all and it
doesn't matter how you choose to watch
nordvpn is available on every modern
platform including Windows iOS Android
Mac OS Linux and even Android TV the
monthly cost is the same as a cup of
coffee regular coffee that is not the
kind that comes from scp-294 and if you
sign up by going to nordvpn.com forward
slash SCP explained you'll even get a
free month so go try it for yourself
right now that's nordvpn.com forward
slash SCP explained now back to your
regularly scheduled programming as we
were saying laugh is fun is a prank show
that puts a knowing everyday people into
ridiculous scenarios and films their
reactions each episode is about 10 to 12
minutes long and features an opening and
closing monologue from beloved
supposedly Human TV vpresenter laughing
mclafferson AKA
scp-2030-1 you've probably seen him
before he's never seen without his blue
three-piece suit and black wingtip shoes
funniest guy on TV seriously I think he
should replace James Corden on The Late
Late Show and maybe even take up hosting
a gig on SNL if he's still got time
after he had this amazing monologue at
the end of an episode in season 32.
all right off folks we've seen printers
that eat eaters that print and
everything in between makes you
appreciate the old clunker you have at
the back office doesn't it no printers
may not always work when you want or
need them to but they sure make for some
excellent comedy and that's what we're
all about here comedy we're here to make
you laugh we hope you laugh thank you
for laughing with us that's what we're
about here doesn't it folks come laugh
with us again next time and remember
laugh is fun good night and laugh and
laugh just laugh we love the make laugh
make more for laughter so as two for
laugh laugh with us laugh with us laugh
with us laugh with us laugh with us
laugh with us laugh laugh laugh laugh
and let us in hmm I couldn't tell you
what his face looks like though because
he's always framed from the neck down
once the pranks are done for the episode
he'll step up on that bright yellow
stage and deliver his closing monologue
which always ends with a pan over the
audience as everyone chance laugh with
us then the show always just cuts to
Black the closest thing the show ever
has to credits is a title card that says
filmed in front of a studio audience in
partnership with
ywtgthft for a show that doesn't
advertise or even air on TV laugh is fun
is still a beloved classic and when you
watch it it's easy to see why it's been
around so long laffy and the team pull
off some really classic pranks on laugh
is laugh there's this one episode in
season 13 where an unsuspecting family
is sitting down to dinner father starts
choking and the family reacts with
horror until suddenly a pair of slits
appear in the father's neck allowing him
to breathe those sleds soon become
nostrils and before you know it a full
second head grows out of his neck that
head then grows its own neck which grows
in noose than a face than another head
than another neck this keeps happening a
total of 18 times while the rest of the
family looks on in horror but don't
worry before things go too far laffy
pops out from under the table and tells
the family they're on laugh is fun
laughy points out the cameras and the
whole family starts laughing including
all 18 of the father's heads there's
also another great season 13 episode
called squirrels oh man okay this one
had me in stitches alright so there's
this couple lying in bed and the wife
wakes up because she hears this
squeaking noise she Taps her husband on
the shoulder to wake him up but she
draws her hand back in horror because
she can feel something moving under her
husband's Skin So before she can ask if
he's okay boom hundreds of squirrels
explode out of his skin and start
running around the room while the wife
screams then laugh he walks in and turns
the lights on accompanied by the husband
who is perfectly okay even though he's
been skinned from head to toe everyone
laughs alright then there's the most
recent episode from season 24 called
swelling there's this old lady sitting
on a park bench feeding the pigeons and
a couple walks past her when they walked
past the old lady gets swarmed by the
pigeon she's feeding the pigeons Force
themselves into her mouth and keep
swarming until her stomach cavity bursts
open the couple who gets sprayed with
guts as to all the pigeons fly off are
extremely distressed by this until laffy
shows up some people say that this
episode is too similar to squirrels and
that the show was starting to get stale
at this point but I think the joke is
unique enough to stand on its own plus
with a prank show as long running as
left it's inevitable that you're gonna
see some jokes get reused really it's
not about the prank itself it's about
the reactions of the people which are
always Priceless and man the way that
laffy mclafferson comes into the frame
by climbing out of the old lady's open
rib cage I was rolling on the floor now
you don't think the old animals
exploding out of people that is funny
okay that's fair enough uh let me think
what are some of my other favorite
episodes of laugh is fun oh yes the
Margaret Thatcher episode from season
21. that's another great thing about
laugh is fun it's not afraid to get a
little political so this woman walks
into your kitchen and opens the cabinet
but instead of the food being in there
it's just a Big Blob of Flesh the flesh
blob rolls out onto the counter and
morphs into a misshapen caricature of
Margaret Thatcher with a
disproportionately big head the woman
starts screaming but the Thatcher
creature jumps onto her pinning her down
and shoving its tongue into her mouth
the deeper the tongue goes the more
Margaret Thatcher faces start appearing
all over the woman's skin all the faces
start reciting Thatcher's April 1986
speech on the bombing of Libya and
perfect Unison you might watch it and
think the woman's going to choke based
on how long the creature's tongue is
down her throat but good old laugh he
comes in and the studio audience goes
nuts laffy points out if the cameras and
says your own life is fun and the woman
starts laughing too with a creature's
tongue still in her mouth but I think my
favorite prank I've ever seen on laugh
is fun was the one from season 37 so
it's in a hospital there's a woman
getting a C-section and all the doctors
are gathered around one of the doctors
makes a comment on how much hair the
baby has and then he screams and drops
his surgical tools the rest of the team
all starts screaming as well and then
this is where it's really funny you see
Ryan Seacrest's head pop up from out of
the woman okay so this is causing her a
lot of pain obviously so she starts
screaming and crying as the Ryan
Seacrest head fully emerges at which
point you can tell that its head is on
an octopus body classic bait and switch
right but that's not the end the Ryan
Seacrest octopus starts singing row row
row your boat as it emerges and then
three more octopi with celebrities heads
come out of this woman there's one that
looks like Jack Nicholson one that looks
like Johnny Cash and one who looks like
Martin Freeman and when they've all come
out of her they start singing together
in four-part harmony it's hilarious
laughy walks in to point out the cameras
and all the doctors start laughing even
the woman on the operating table is
laughing in fact she laughs so hard she
passes out it's a real shame that there
are never any end credits because it
would be so cool to find out more about
the people who make this show I mean
their total comedic Geniuses and special
effects Wizards too I couldn't even
guess how they do some of those pranks
but sadly there's very little
information about the Show online and
you you can't even ask the victims of
the pranks about it because all of them
are dead what no no no no no not because
of laugh is fun that's just a prank show
it's all jokes they always show everyone
laughing and perfectly okay at the end
no matter how badly they got mutilated
in the episode you can even see some
people who have been on previous
episodes among the studio audiences if
you look hard enough but okay by total
coincidence everyone who is featured on
laugh is fun eventually dies or is
already dead of totally unrelated causes
like the Turman family dad Gary Turman
was the one who had 18 extra heads grow
out of his neck Gary his wife Lindsay
and their two kids tragically passed
away in a car wreck on the 28th of April
1989. Melissa and Travis younglin the
couple from the squirrel prank went
missing and were last seen on the 12th
of May 1989. the couple from the pigeon
prank Macy Gershon and Kyle Parker were
both killed by a hit-and-run driver in
September of 2000. Doris Carter the
woman from the Thatcher prank passed
away from ovarian cancer in 1997 and
Rebecca Nash the woman who gave birth to
all those singing celebrity cephalopods
died in childbirth in 2013. you might
think that the last one had something to
do with her laugh is fun episode due to
the hospital connection but the
surgeon's present when she died didn't
report anything strange happening at the
time all these deaths happen in roughly
the same years that all these people had
their appearances on laugh but it's
because it's only available on streaming
and video it can't really be said what
the connection is since there aren't any
air dates for any of the episodes while
you might assume that these people died
after their appearances on laugh and the
show is actually some kind of death
curse it's just as likely that they died
before and laugh is fun is somehow
filmed and distributed from the great
beyond some people even think that the
people who film laugh actually kidnap
all the people who appear on the show
and fake their deaths in some kind of
big Sinister conspiracy sure I have
heard that all the people who supposedly
died after being on the show have
inconsistencies in their death records
and that many of their graves actually
just told empty coffins but still that
feels totally unrealistic to me I mean
come on can you really picture TV's own
laughy laugherson kidnapping anyone he
has such a friendly attitude like I said
before no information whatsoever exists
about the way this show is made not even
the SCP Foundation has any answers
they're still actively investigating the
ways in which people get chosen to be on
laugh as fun as well as where it's
filmed and who produces it talk about a
really Niche cult hit I hope I've sold
you on laugh as fun it may not be that
well known and you might have trouble
finding it but trust me it's the
funniest prank show you'll probably ever
watch I guarantee once you get into it
it'll make you laugh and laugh and laugh
laugh with us laugh with us laugh with
us laugh with us have you ever wanted to
be in a cartoon they have it easier than
we do that's for sure the characters in
your favorite shows never seem to
experience boring days and the world
around them always seems so wonderful
and imaginative animation is an
idealized stylized form of reality where
anything can happen and entertainment is
at the Forefront of the lived experience
if you're understanding the appeal
behind what we're talking about you'll
definitely be interested in hearing
about
scp-6080 a strange anomaly known as
Eric's cartoon box the story of Eric's
cartoon box is elaborate and complex but
catalog's one of the foundation's most
imaginative and surreal anomalies on
file it started on parawatch.net a
message board dedicated to the
Supernatural and paranormal that the
foundation likes to keep tabs on in
their spare time while sifting through
countless fake posts about being
abducted by aliens or hunting for
bigfoot the foundation noticed something
less conventional that caught their eye
a series of posts that talked about a
cursed VHS tape of the mid 90s classic
Nickelodeon cartoon soon Rocco's Modern
Life Now a curse cartoon seems like your
standard internet horror fiction fair
something the foundation could easily
dismiss as a story crafted by an amateur
author but what caught their attention
were the pictures of strange entities
that appeared as a result of watching
the tape as well as information on how
the original poster obtained the tape it
seemed oddly specific a tape purchased
on eBay through a seller named tune
collector the foundation conducted a
brief investigation and found that tune
collector was a resident of Bakersfield
California named Jacob Sawyer who had
gone missing sometime in the past inside
his house the foundation found several
VHS tapes and DVD cases as well as a
television a hard drive on Sawyer's
computer contained 161 hours of brief
edited videos all reviewing and
commenting on various cartoons seems
like Sawyer had a video essay hobby but
the foundation was unable to locate any
of this content on Major Video hosting
sites in Sawyer's basement the
foundation discovered a large worn out
cardboard box on its right side were the
words Eric's cartoon box written in
Black Sharpie on its front was a
simplistic smiley face also drawn in
Sharpie originally the foundation
thought it was just an ordinary box but
the object quickly proved itself to be
alive capable of speaking despite a lack
of vocal cords and also possessing a
large degree of Mobility propelling
itself short distances to move when the
foundation first came across scp-6080 in
Sawyer's basement the object was clearly
distressed
scp-6080 and all of the other items
found were taken into Foundation custody
and moved to site 433 where they would
be researched by Dr Rowan raster one of
the foundation's leading figures in the
study of animated anomalous media and
art rasters research found that
scp-6080 when emotionally distressed
could Bend reality to alter their
surroundings which were transformed into
reflections of its psyche raster
discovered that there were a few ways to
pacify
scp-6080 but the most practical method
was to evoke a sense of nostalgia in the
object by placing it in a familiar
environment to ensure that the box is
kept passive
scp-6080 is kept inside a containment
chamber resembling a child's bedroom an
environment
scp-6080 finds comforting on top of
their reality bending abilities
scp-6080 also produces DVDs and VHS
tapes labeled
scp-6080-1 the foundation would later
discover that the tapes found within
Sawyer's home and the cursed Rocco's
Modern Life tape discussed on
parawatch.net where all products of
scp-6080 but what's so special about the
cartoon reproductions made by 6080 on
the outside there are unaltered copies
of animated children's television shows
and films and their contents are exactly
the same as their ordinary counterparts
however once an instance of
scp-6080-1 is viewed the subject
watching it will experience a reality
altering anomalous experience dubbed by
the research team as a rerun event
sometimes the rerun event occurs
immediately though research has shown
that as much time as three weeks can
pass before one occurs rerun events
often reflect visual or thematic
elements of the media that induce them
and their severity ranges from
inconsequential to dangerous and harmful
to their subjects because of the variety
found in a rerun event's content it is
difficult to generalize them but we'll
be sure to get into the specifics of a
few later on still if the event isn't
immediately dangerous to the subject the
foundation discovered that a re-run
event May leave involved persons with
lingering physical and cycle logical
alterations some of which are unable to
be fully alleviated or treated even with
amnestics soon after scp-6080 was
brought into site-433 and the immediate
characteristics of the anomaly were
recorded an interview between the box
and researcher Rowan raster was held
Rowan tried to make sure that the
anomaly was as comfortable as possible
but scp-6080 continued to shuffle
against the floor rapidly unsettled in
their new environment
scp-6080 wanted to get out and the
object continued to stress themselves
out to the point where its speech
degraded into unintelligibility the
lights in the containment chamber began
flickering on and off and the face on
the front of the Box rapidly flipped
between different Expressions Rowan
tried to continue to get through to
scp-6080 and eventually they began to
speak they said that they were scared
and that they missed someone that they
called Eric
scp-6080 once calmed down down explained
that Eric was the center of their
Universe in their own words
scp-6080 felt when it first started
existing that their sole purpose for
being here on Earth was to exist for
Eric they remembered waking up in a
bedroom filled with toys and posters and
immediately knowing the feeling that
they knew what they were made for and
who they were made by at first this was
overwhelming and scp-6080 began to freak
out but Eric showed concern and the Box
realized that they didn't want to upset
him the most important thing for
scp-6080 was to not upset Eric when
raster asked if they could describe Eric
the box was unable to and said that
whenever they tried to talk about Eric's
appearance people became confused they
said that Eric's skin was blue and that
he had a purple nose with dark red eyes
and four thin strands of hair on top of
his head from the way they described
Eric he sounded exactly like a cartoon
character raster asked if this was how
scp-6080 always saw people and that
seemed to be the case
scp-6080 then explained how they used
their abilities to make Eric happy
namely through producing tapes of Eric's
favorite cartoons and then playing
inside the worlds of the shows together
and this continued for a while
scp-6080 and Eric would meet the
characters from their favorite shows and
Adventure through their worlds and the
two developed a powerful Bond but
eventually as scp-6080 explained Eric
left one day the Box woke up and their
friend was gone
scp-6080 even searched for Eric's
friends but found that they were gone
too without Eric
scp-6080 was alone and they panicked
they ran outside the house and began
asking anyone they could find if they
knew where Eric went naturally the
people as cp-68 he spoke to were
terrified and scp-6080 quickly became
overwhelmed by the chaos of the outside
world and then they found Jacob Sawyer
Sawyer was at first just as scared of
scp-6080 as everyone else was but once
scp-6080 opened its flaps and revealed a
trove of old tapes Sawyer smiled to
himself and told the box that it would
be useful before picking them up and
taking them to his house
scp-6080 was scared and attempted to
flee from Sawyer the more time the Box
spent with Sawyer the sicker it felt
when Sawyer threw the box in the empty
White Walls of his basement
scp-6080 was forced by Jacob to open
themselves up and produce tapes for
months this is how scp-6080 lived alone
in a white-walled room with white floors
and white ceilings being forced open and
used as a dispenser for the tapes which
Sawyer would sell online
scp-6080 stopped their account and began
crying a substance that resembled
blueberry syrup raster put a stop to the
interview realizing that the object was
clearly experiencing a form of trauma
after a break raster asked scp-6080 if
they knew what happened to Sawyer the
Box explained that one day Sawyer rushed
down into the basement and demanded
scp-6080 to explain what it was doing to
the cartoons it made apparently some of
the buyers were realizing that scp-68
these tapes were anything but normal
Sawyer brutalized the box and pulled the
DVD from inside them but when Sawyer
watched the DVD for himself all scp-6080
heard from beneath the living room was a
sharp burst of static and a horrible
scream after that Jacob was gone
scp-6080 couldn't recall what tape they
had produced that caused Sawyer to
disappear nor was one matching the Box's
description found inside the house after
the interview the foundation began its
testing with with scp-6080 inside its
containment chamber
scp-6080 would produce a tape a d-class
Personnel would watch it and the ensuing
rerun event was recorded during testing
scp-6080 was escorted from the room so
as to not cause it emotional distress
most of these tests were routine a
d-class would watch an episode of a
cartoon such as ChalkZone or the Rugrats
and strange reality altering events
would occur for example after watching
an episode of The Rugrats where Chucky
had difficulty differentiating his
dreams from reality
d1711 experienced a rerun event in which
he was disoriented d-1711 claimed
everything in the room looked tall and
that they needed to sleep off the
effects of the anomaly after laying in
the bed the chamber's lights turned blue
and purple and a humanoid entity wearing
a researcher's outfit was seen facing
the corner of the room against the wall
the figure disappeared as quickly as it
appeared with laughter heard in the
distance as soon as the figure was gone
d-1711 jolted awake and began screaming
after this the researcher observing the
experiment rushed in and like a
concerned parent began comforting d1711
the researcher assured the d-class that
nothing in a dream could hurt them
because it isn't real which was a direct
quote from the Rugrats episode d1711
watched after this the d-class and the
researcher came out of their trance
State wondering how they got inside the
containment chamber and what they were
doing there the rerun event had finished
and d1711 explained that while they were
asleep they dreamed events similar to
The Dream shown in the Rugrats episode
this is just one example of how odd and
surreal rerun events can be another test
involving an obscure cartoon by the name
of King resulting in the entirety of
site 433 undergoing changes that made it
look as if it were a location from the
show itself however the most notable
rerun event occurred when the foundation
tested a tape of cartoon All-Stars to
the rescue a special featuring cartoon
characters from various shows banding
together to talk about the dangers of
children using drugs in order to conduct
this test
d-9926 was sent to a quarantine
Community away from site 433 with only a
helmet mounted camera and a
communication headset 10 hours after
watching the tape
d-9926 slept inside a bedroom of the
vacant building the foundation had
brought him to he was woken by the sound
of a doorknob jittering and then several
knocks Dean 9926 got up from the bed and
opened the door to find four crude
looking entities resembling cartoon
characters from the special one was
Kermit the Frog who was puppeteered by a
man in a gray hoodie another was a
cardboard cutout of Bugs Bunny there was
a tall mascot like Garfield costume and
and a sentient Alf plush the four
entities crowded d-9926 and began
singing to him in a shrill high-pitched
voice a song about the dangers of doing
drugs
d-9926 was confused but the trance
induced by the anomaly made it difficult
for him to think straight then from the
open windowsill in the room came a black
boot attached to a long leg a fifth
entity made its way into the room
crawling through the windowsill it was a
tall grayskin humanoid with wrinkled
trousers a crease shirt and a large
necktie as much as dean9926 could
understand the gray entity was not from
a cartoon the gray entity signal d9926
towards them and the two left the
building and the strange cartoon
entities behind outside the environment
was strange it was dark out with only
dim street lights Illuminating the
spaces between trees at a low angle the
asphalt path The Duo locked on slowly
transitioned to a field of grass the
gray entity explained that the very
nature of the environment was built
around the message of the cartoon which
was trying to get Dean 9926 to avoid
using drugs somehow Dean 9926 needed to
find a way to get out as the two moved
through the forest area
d-9926 and the gray entity continued to
recognize something was wrong gray
explained that it didn't understand
where they were either and that's when
d-9926's rerun event began altering
reality it was pulled away from the
place it regularly existed and into
reality
d-9926 did not understand that he was
short on options both of them smelled
something horrible and the area around
them was starting to resemble the real
world less and less the sky above the
forest was Smoky orange red and in the
distance Dean 9926 could see a
luminescent object resembling a window
recessed into a concrete wall the two
also heard music and as they moved
through this dreamlike world they came
across a building in the distance which
was small enough for them to climb the
roof of on the roof there appeared to be
a parking lot and Beyond its more Forest
as if they never elevated from the
ground in the first place the two
continued walking as the parking lot
sloped downwards they recognized what
appeared to be a city in the distance
Dean knew that with the altered state of
reality this city was going to be
anything but normal but he felt
compelled to keep moving it was the only
thing the two of them could do
d9926 and the gray entity began talking
about the nature of the reality they
found themselves in and the entity
explained that it felt that trusting its
gut and exploring anything that stood
out was probably the right thing to do
in a place that made little actual sense
they concluded that the location they
were inside had some sort of feelings
and goals and they just had to go along
with its own internal logic in order to
find a way out in the distance the red
lights of the city twinkled in the
darkness they continued walking after 30
minutes the red lights of the city
illuminated all of their surroundings
they began to see the edifices of
concrete buildings on the other side of
the road they were walking on
d-9926 didn't notice them at first but
when the entity pointed them out
d-9926 realized they were standing in
the middle of a mass of buildings with
rubble and litter strewn on the streets
beneath them gray wondered if they could
use them as shelter the two didn't
realize that they were being watched by
a figure in the distance
d-9926 was still confused the city was
empty gray seemed oddly optimistic about
their situation and things weren't
looking like they were going to return
to normal anytime soon gray commented
that they were somewhat interested in
exploring location different from the
realities and dreams they were used to
exploring after minutes of nothing the
duo came across a dead body laying on
top of a rusted metal wheelbarrow
d-9926 who was familiar with seeing
sites like these sighed and continued
moving gray told him he could simply
walk away into the darkness where they
could forget about this place and emerge
somewhere else
d-9926 wondered if the entity really had
that power they came across more bodies
and continued forward if this entity
could really whisk d-9926 away to
another place he was seriously
considering it life as a d-class was
unimaginably dehumanizing the figure
watching the two of them continued to
observe from a rooftop suddenly a large
sheet metal shelving unit fell from the
overhanging roof of a building tipped
from its Edge by the observing figure
the shelving unit hit gray directly and
severely injured The Entity on impact
d-99 26 ran he ran through the buildings
only catching glimpses of the orange
figure wielding a thick pipe running
across the rooftops beside him the chase
continued through the insides of the
buildings and once Dean 9926 caught a
glimpse of the pursuing figure he ran
back out the entire time he heard the
figure's high-pitched breathing audibly
chasing after him more bodies more red
lighting and Endless City all while
being pursued
d-9926 found rest inside a warehouse
which he ran through in an attempt to
escape the entity at the far side of the
warehouse was a room resembling
scp-6080s containment chamber but
heavily damaged and littered with trash
the television set in the room switched
on showed an all-white room similar to
the basement
scp-6080 was found in the door to the
room was about to be opened and Dean
9926 screamed before smashing the TV
with a book he threw from across the
room upon shattering the screen the
camera feed went dark when it resumed
d9926 found himself in a red Misty area
with a figure that had been pursuing him
standing right in front of him the two
stared at each other before the figure
lunged forward at Dean 99-26 but then it
suddenly stopped and the voice of
scp-6080 was heard the Box called out to
the figure which it recognized as
something that resembled Jacob Sawyer
scp-6080 ordered the Sawyer entity to
leave Dean 9926 alone except this time
scp-6080 wasn't a cardboard box they
were a pale skin child drawn like a
cartoon wearing ordinary clothes the Box
realized that this place was a
manifestation of its own traumatic
experience as it slowly realized that
the entity resembling Sawyer was stuck
in its own mind the box and and the
entity fought each other punching with
large cartoon-like fists until the
Sawyer entity fell to the ground
coughing up blood
scp-6080 realized that this wasn't
actually Sawyer like everything this was
all a manifestation of the damage that
Sawyer caused and with that the entity
left its own body flattening until all
that was left was its empty skin Dean
9926 thanked scp-6080 for saving him and
the two introduced themselves to one
another
scp-6080 offered to take d9926 away from
the foundation forever he took off his
recording equipment and the two walked
away into the sunset inside
scp-6080s containment chamber the object
and d9926 were nowhere to be found
instead there was a single disc
containing a message from scp-6080 to
the foundation
scp-6080 told the foundation that they
were coming to terms with what they
experienced in their life and that now
they were in a place where they could
exist without issue behind them was a
playground where scp-6080 could act like
a kid again something they never got to
experience as much as they wanted to
they told the foundation that Dean 9926
was safe and happy somewhere else and
that they shouldn't look for either of
them because they'd never find them for
now all scp-6080 needed to do was to
play on the swings and live at peace
with themselves until they could grow up
inside the disc that the message was
contained on was a sticky note that
simply read I hope you understand video
games have come a long way over the
years we've gone from the days of Atari
and pong to Virtual Reality headsets
ps5s and massive multiplayer online
games where you can fight horror movie
villains or wage war in a fantasy land
you can mine virtual minerals and avoid
creepers and Minecraft compete against
people all over the world in fortnite
and do whatever it is people do in
Roblox games used to be a pixelated hero
battling Blobby monsters with no
discernible facial features and now they
have Graphics so detailed you can see
the freckles on a protagonist's face and
each individual blade of grass but
there's one thing that hasn't changed no
matter how much progress games may make
whenever a shiny new console comes out
everyone wants to get their hands on it
it was Christmas season in 1986. Walk
Like an Egyptian by The Bangles was at
the top of the charts Eddie Murphy's The
Golden Child was the number one movie in
America and hundreds of thousands of
kids were writing to Santa and begging
their parents for one thing the Nintendo
Entertainment System the NES was an
8-bit home video game console and the
only place to Journey Through the land
of Hyrule in The Legend of Zelda or help
Samus hunt space pirates in Metroid but
with such an extreme demand for the
system stores were selling out all over
the country anyone who didn't beat the
crowds was doomed to disappoint their
kids with socks with less flashy toys
like dolls or tiny plastic trucks or
with boring non-electric violence-free
board games well board games are only
violence free if you're not playing
Monopoly but back to 1986. Beverly
Harrington was a single mom doing her
best to provide for her son Jason and
give him the Christmas he deserved she
had been picking up extra shifts at the
local Diner making sure to save up all
the extra money for a real Christmas
tree from the farm just out of town for
a beautiful honey baked ham and of
course for presents she knew that though
he was a shy kid and would never demand
it Jason desperately wanted to find an
NES under the tree on Christmas morning
she got so absorbed in her work so
exhausted from the extra shifts and
trying to make everything perfect that
she forgot to do her actual shopping
until the very last minute she woke up
the morning of December 24th with a
start her heart jumping into her throat
she hadn't picked up Jason's present yet
she threw on her coat and rushed out
into the snowy streets making her way to
the store and sang a silent prayer that
they would still have one more NES in
stock lucky for her they did less lucky
two parents were already wrestling for
it fighting each other with a raw
animalistic Rage of two wolves competing
for the same piece of meat if she tried
to grab it and join in she could get
hurt or the console could break apart
she asked an employee if they had any in
the back but she already knew the answer
from the exhausted book in his eyes
there were no more in the back there
were no more in town nor the next town
over or the next town over from that not
only would she have to get Jason's
present at the very last minute but she
would also have to get him something he
didn't even want he would smile and
thank her but she knew how sad it would
make him to go back to school and hear
his friends bragging about their
Christmases she shot their hands into
the pockets of her coat and began her
slow sad March back through the snow
trying to come up with what to do next
then something caught her eye a brightly
colored sign reading Wonder taming toys
beneath it it was a storefront she had
never seen before and right there in the
window a video game console it wasn't
the NES not exactly but it looked so
much like it she couldn't help herself
she had to go inside and get a better
look the store was filled with toys
games and puzzles they were all inviting
with Vivid packaging and labels
depicting children having fun but she
had never seen any of them before
perhaps it was a new brand and she was
one of the first people to happen upon
the store it seemed odd for a toy store
to open this close to Christmas rather
than taking advantage of the shopping
season and opening earlier in the year
but she couldn't dwell on that not when
she was this close to a solution toward
the back of the store she spotted the
video game console from the window the
label read pretendo so the resemblance
to the NES was no coincidence this
console was intended as a knockoff of
some kind she asked the sales clerk a
man with a strangely wide unmoving smile
if the console was capable of running
Nintendo games you bet your bottom
dollar you replied
he don't carry those here though but can
I interest you in some of our
wondertainment Originals we have all
kinds of games here and they're just as
good or your money back there's a whole
world inside each and every one it
wasn't what she'd set out to buy but
this was clearly the best thing Beverly
was going to find this close to the
holiday she paid the man for the
pretendo console and a selection of the
store's most popular video games he even
gift wrapped it for her in a colorful
box with a shiny red bow on top the next
morning Jason and Beverly sat in the
living room sipping Coco and opening
presents together she started small with
a classic pair of new wool socks and
worked her way up to the big box in the
corner as Jason tore the paper off his
eyes lit up with Glee thank you Mom
thank you he gave her a huge hug then
looked at her with nearly manic
excitement can I play it now can I she
laughed and promised that after he
helped her clean up the wrapping paper
he could play his new games she was just
so glad he was happy with it he didn't
care that it wasn't the name brand
console he knew that this gift was
special so she was perfectly glad to let
him enjoy it and she could get started
on that ham for later Jason plugged in
his brand new pretendo and looked
through the games his mom had picked out
for him there was farmtastic Farming
Simulator Historical house Hunter magic
Wizard Quest super Fighters and one
simply called spooky it was emblazoned
with the image of a cartoon ghost in
front of an abandoned cabin and it
peaked Jason's interest he always loved
scary stories and legends about ghosts
and Things That Go Bump in the night he
decided that this would be the first
game that he would play he placed the
cartridge in the console and hit the
power button to turn it on as he
clutched the controller in his hands he
began to notice something strange his
room once decorated in posters of his
favorite movies turned dark the light
green Walls became rotting wood and for
lack of a better way to describe it the
entire world's resolution began to shift
if the world around him had Graphics
they were getting worse he can no longer
see the screen depicting the game's main
menu and in fact the console itself had
vanished somehow he was standing in the
Haunted Cabin from the cover of the game
he looked down at his hands and found
the controller still there so not
everything had changed before he could
think any more about this strange new
place he found himself in he heard the
sound of ominous music seemingly coming
from nowhere after a moment he realized
why the sound of its Melody filled him
with dread it was the kind of music that
always played in a game when an enemy
was getting close he had to move he took
a step forward and moved through the
space as if it was a real house for the
time being it was somehow he was inside
the game which meant the ghost was
coming for him soon he pressed a button
on the controller to activate a
flashlight and followed its beam through
the darkened cabin as he walked looking
for clues or any object he could
interact with he could hear the music
getting louder whatever was coming it
was getting closer the flashlight's beam
illuminated the scrap of paper on a
small table he moved to take a closer
look and could just barely make out what
it said they hide in the Darkness find
the exit don't stop moving he heard a
sound behind him and the music reached a
deafening volume he Whirled around and
saw nothing but the hull in front of him
bending around a corner he knew from the
heavy feeling in the pit of his stomach
and the music that threatened to rupture
his eardrums that there was something
horrible waiting for him around that
corner he froze for a moment then
remember the letters words of warning
don't stop moving he took a step towards
the corner then another and another he
shown the light of the flashlight around
the corner but there was nothing there
no ghost no monster nothing and then he
felt it a chill on the back of his neck
he Whirled around and there it was the
Ghost of the cabin who was so much
bigger than it had looked before wispy
white forms stretching up to the ceiling
from wall to wall its wide dark eyes and
gaping mauve a mouth inches from his own
face he screamed and instinctively swung
the flashlight at the Spirit cutting
through it with a beam of light the
ghost let out a shriek and shrank away
from the glow that was it he just needed
to keep the light on it and the ghost
couldn't hurt him Jason was so thrilled
by this little victory that he didn't
even notice the Boss music starting to
play again growing louder and louder he
didn't see the movement out of the
corner of his eye the Silvery pale
figure of a woman stepping out of a
portrait on the wall all he felt was a
sudden overwhelming cold like ice in his
veins and then everything went black he
opened his eyes back in his bedroom
looking at a dark screen with the words
game over written in dripping red font
he couldn't tell for a moment if that
had been real or a dream but either way
he only wanted to do one thing tell his
mom Beverly listened to her son's story
and couldn't help but write it off as
the overactive imagination of a child
but still she humored him and agreed to
try the console for her self and see
what happened choosing at random she
selected farmtastic and pressed play all
of a sudden she felt the heat of the sun
on her face heard the mooing of cows and
smelled fresh cut hay she was steering a
tractor through a wide open field where
a moment ago she had been standing in
her house in the dead of winter Jason
shut off the game pulling her back into
reality and as Beverly gasped in shock
Jason said best present ever
unfortunately for Jason word was already
spreading about the pretendo all the way
to the SCP Foundation the console and
all other consoles at the foundation
could track down were seized and
designated
scp-591
scp-591 is a line of video game consoles
originally developed as a counterfeit of
the Nintendo Entertainment System before
being bought and distributed by Dr
wondertainment a toy company responsible
for a wide variety of anomalous objects
contained by the foundation over the
years the console is capable of playing
any titles as well as games from Dr
wondertainment's original lineup of
8-bit games many of which the foundation
has in its possession as well some of
the titles in the SCP foundations
Library include but are not limited to
Arcade shooter wapham platformer dusky's
adventures in stadeland survival horror
game you can do that on television
puzzle game World War one ace trench
digger music racing game Led Zeppelin
Air Racers fighting games super Kick
karate and super Kick karate 2010 and
the educational game Reading Rainbow sit
and listen whenever one of the official
Dr wondertainment cartridges is inserted
into the console and activated it
results in a localized CK class reality
restructuring scenario which rearranges
reality in the immediate area to
resemble the game's setting the player
inside of the game's affected radius
will take on the role of the game's
protagonist and navigate the events of
the game until either they win or the
console is deactivated don't worry this
isn't one of those if you die in the
game you die in real life scenarios if
the player happens to be a less than
Adept gamer they will simply respawn or
start at the beginning of the game like
any video game character would that
doesn't however mean that
scp-591 isn't dangerous like any piece
of vintage technology the components of
the pretendo system have degraded over
time their functionality steadily
decreasing for an ordinary game console
this would be a simple inconvenience
something that would impact the quality
of the graphics or responsiveness of the
controls it would be annoying and maybe
eventually unplayable but otherwise
harmless for the pretendo however this
degradation has had catastrophic events
when a game cartridge is inserted into
scp-591 there is now a chance of the CK
class reality restructuring scenario
going wrong and resulting in a ZK class
reality failure scenario instead
essentially instead of just transporting
the player into the world of the game
reality will crumble in the designated
area and the laws of time space and
physics will be bent or even broken
while the CK class scenarios dissipate
as soon as the console is deactivated
the ZK class scenarios refuse to play by
the rules they remain in place wherever
they first manifested seemingly
permanently the ZK class scenarios were
first observed during play testing by
the research staff assigned to scp-591
after learning about the nature of the
pretendo game system Dr Furukawa has
volunteered as a test subject
specifically requesting that he be given
the chance to play the doctor
wondertainment title The Legend of
swordmaster because quote it just looks
really cool this particular game came
with not just the cartridge but a
special sword-shaped controller to be
used during the sword fight sequences Dr
furtakawa stepped into the containment
cell where one instance of scp-591 had
been placed with his chosen game
cartridge and controller waiting for him
as soon as he inserted the cartridge
into the console and pressed the start
button the room around him began to
transform reality itself warping and
reshaping to fit the world of the game
fluorescent lights and stark white walls
were replaced by pixelated trees and a
winding Cobblestone path leading to a
massive Stone Castle the first enemy a
knight in black armor leapt into frame
and Dr Furukawa raised his sword ready
for combat but before he had a chance to
deal the first blow it became clear that
something wasn't right the enemy Knight
suddenly disappeared glitching out of
sight the Cobblestone slowly began to
drift into the air and so did Dr
frodakawa just as suddenly as he lifted
off he dropped back to the ground with a
heavy thud gravity was rapidly
fluctuating and he could scarcely keep
his balance in front of him he could see
random cubic structures popping up out
of nowhere made of wood Stone and ice
and the game he called out desperately
pull the plugs someone please outside
one of the the researchers watching The
Experiment cut the power to the console
but nothing happened the world refused
to return to normal security officers
entered the area and attempted to remove
Dr fotokawa but found that his body
still resembled an 8-bit video game
character when they attempted to drag
him out of the ZK class zone he cried
out in pain as his body began to
dissolve into static they had turned off
the console but they were unable to pull
him out the rest of the research team
horrified by what they had witnessed
began to take measurements of the
reality failure scenario from outside of
the room the area now displayed a
complete absence of naturally occurring
radiation including cosmic background
radiation there was also evidence of
time dilation reduction of light speed
and the gravity fluctuations that Dr
Furukawa had first noticed with no way
to remove Furukawa from this broken
reality the area would have to be sealed
off and he would be left inside there
was no other option so they constructed
a concrete Dome around the testing site
and relocated the remaining instances of
scp-591 from that point on testing was
only conducted using d-classes no matter
how much research staff loved video
games or how vehemently they insisted
that they were quote willing to roll the
dice they were barred from testing and
encouraged to pick up a VR headset for a
much lower risk immersive gaming
experience over the years of testing
following the Dr fotokawa incident four
more ZK class scenarios were created and
contained some of the individuals
survived the incident but were
physically altered so greatly that they
would not be able to survive outside of
the ZK class reality failure the only
people who survived were unable to
readjust to their lives continuing to
live as the main character of the game
that they were playing at this point
testing was officially suspended
indefinitely due to not only the loss of
human life but also the unpredictable
and highly dangerous nature of the
damage being done to reality on such a
grand scale All In chances of scp-591
confiscated by the foundation are kept
in a storage containment Vault kept
separate from any civilians or their
infrastructure by a distance of at least
500 meters it is also kept separate from
other foundation-controlled containment
facilities unless it is being used for
official approved testing by level 3
staff it is to remain deactivated at all
times any ZK class scenarios created by
an instance of scp-591 will be contained
via the construction of a closed
concrete Dome and given the designation
of sector W number sectors W1 through W5
the currently existing ZK class
scenarios are monitored remotely and
kept highly classified any Personnel or
test subjects located inside one of
these sectors will remain there
indefinitely and be officially
considered Lost In Action any additional
instances of scp-591 located in civilian
stores households or any public place
are to be removed and contained
indefinitely as the years have gone by
testing has indicated a steady increase
in the rate of ZK class scenarios being
generated from a CK class scenario where
it was only a one percent chance there
is now a 32 chance according to
wondertainment company records seized
during a foundation rate of one of their
toy factories there are still plenty of
scp-591 instances out there in the world
just waiting for some unsuspecting gamer
to fire them up and get lost in the
story literally if the documents found
are accurate there are around 243
consoles and 1300 consoles still in
circulation these Also may or may not
include a pocket pretendo model that was
developed as a prototype but never
officially released on the market if it
was and the chaos of the pretendo system
is available in a portable form while
it's best not to think about that for
too long the foundation is doing its
best to track down the remaining
pretendo systems but there is no way to
know for sure what distant corners of
the world they've made their way to so
when you're picking up a shiny new game
console or a nostalgic vintage model to
relive some of your favorite childhood
memories with take an extra close look
at the label and make sure you're
getting the real thing because if you're
not careful it just might be game over
modern cognitive Neuroscience tells us
that our memories are about as reliable
as a weatherman at your local news
channel when a couple is asked how did
you first meet they are lured into
romanticized reflection they might
recall locking eyes at a school dance
they might recall the night being just
perfect despite the truth being far from
it we don't remember the spilled punch
the stepped on toes or the
stuttering we only remember the X's and
O's our memory doesn't find the needle
by sifting through the haystack but
rather by lighting a match and setting
the barn Ablaze until All That Remains
is the small piece of silver shining
through the smoke in this way our
memories are our best friend
they know exactly when to lie to us
feeding us misinformation about the past
to satisfy ourselves in the present
because if humans were capable of
writing and recalling accurate personal
accounts of their history our memories
would be stiff unmarketable literature
and when a book gets boring we tend to
tap out just the same when our lives get
monotonous we tend to give up so we have
our faulty biased brains to thank us for
our perceived happiness and fulfillment
our inaccurate memory systems
consequently help us hide trauma
contrive purpose and Infuse unique
importance into an otherwise banal
existence but let it be known not all
cerebral restructurings are gifts from
psychology some are curses from scps
which of these two possibilities is more
existentially terrifying is up to you
scp-5040 is a non-existent Japanese
horror film entitled Tears of Blood
which spontaneously manifests inhuman
memories
scp-5040 is a master of persuasion those
affected by scp-5040 will remember going
to see the film even when their supposed
attendance would contradict empirical
evidence it manipulates the Mind into
unwavering Faith while humans
occasionally stumble upon the
self-awareness to question their
recollection there are no documented
instances of an individual doubting this
specific memory somehow beyond the
foundation's understanding
scp-5040 manages to suspend the
skepticism of its victims they accept
the memory as Canon as brute fact
victims of scp-5040 do not need a ticket
stub to know they have been to the
theater and scp-5040 afflictions can
occur any place where movies are shown
it even transcends laws and navigates
social norms in cultures where its
content would usually be prohibited by
regulations and frowned upon by the
public
still inserts itself into the memory of
its prey and once that memory is planted
it's an event that can't be forgotten
like the birth of your first child like
your favorite football team winning the
Super Bowl like the employee number you
punch in and out of work every day for
the rest of your life it stamps itself
into the Forefront of the subject's
brain waving its arm pleading to be
recognized begging for attention
descriptions of the film are always
similar in nature as are the
circumstances and events surrounding the
viewing however reports of scp-540's
story and characters are never fully
consistent from one subject to the next
in the film setting subplots character
names and much of the dialogue are
different for each viewer whether this
is scp-5040s intent or inadequacy is
unclear casting also varies and appears
largely arbitrary a broad variety of
Japanese performers and entertainment
personalities both living and deceased
have been and said to star in the film
even when the actor in question has no
real life associations with the horror
genre imagine famous Japanese actor Pat
Morita better known as Mr Miyagi from
the karate kid being the lead in a
horror film despite the fact this would
be a noticeably strange casting decision
scp-5040 would still be taken seriously
despite any and all deviations from
expectations of the medium
scp-5040 is seen as legitimate kinks in
its design are overlooked by the viewer
similar to how our sleeping selves most
often don't recognize we are dreaming
even when we encounter flying horses
friends with banana fingers and
leprechauns playing Pot Limit Omaha in
Chris Hemsworth's basement this may be
because despite all of its quirks the
film's core is sturdy it's beginning
middle and end are always in agreement
it doesn't stray from Robert McKee's
Universal structure of story not even
the sick twisted Night Shyamalan himself
could have created a cinematic
experience quite like this after
conducting more than 300 interviews
researchers have constructed a detailed
synopsis of scp-5040's most consistent
story elements and the most common
sequence of events associated with the
viewer's memory of their screening
attendance there is no matinee with this
movie screenings always begin at Sunset
if there are obstacles standing in the
way of the subject's attendance
scp-5040 will see them removed dentist
appointments drinks with a friend a long
procrastinated date with the treadmill
all these commitments for that day and
time will be pushed down the subjects
list of priorities making way for the
movie they will learn that their plans
have been canceled or resolved one way
or another the dentist's office burned
to the ground your friend is suddenly
sober the model of treadmills at your
gym have been recalled somehow someway
time is is freed up and when life is
kind enough to offer respite from
personal and social obligations it is
modern humans instinct to sit down and
veg out at this moment the subjects
decide to see a movie at a nearby
theater upon arrival the theater looks
to be an entity in its own right long
lines of patrons are like limbs
extending from its Center box office
bright blocky letters forming the film's
title run across the Marquee like a
cheap tattoo it is truly Madness a
frenzied crowd gathers at the box office
pushing and shoving clawing at the glass
partition for a ticket the entire
theater has been reserved for this
special event a one-time only screening
of a rare critically acclaimed film
admission is entirely free but is it
actually free or has the cost just not
declared itself when the subject reaches
the auditorium they scanned their eyes
over the sea of people heads emerge from
the backs of almost every seat they can
only find one empty space and they have
to shuffle like a crab to get past the
mass of other viewers in their seat they
notice that a large number of people
throughout the audience are wearing
disposable face masks the woman sitting
next to the subject's right wears one
such mask as does the woman on their
left and before you think well that
isn't so weird it's important to note
that all of these accounts were taken
years before certain recent events
patrons continue to pack into the
theater despite every chair being filled
more and more people enter the Isles
become overflow seating regulations of
Max occupancy are dismissed in the
darkness of the room all that can be
clearly seen are shapes the rectangle
that is the screen the hundreds of
circles that are the heads of the
audience but there is a shape that feels
misplaced what appears to be the letter
P sticks up from the crowd a thin line
with a bulge protruding from the top the
specificity of its origin is difficult
to Define
but once the subject's eyes adjust to
the dark they notice it's an IV pole
carrying a bag of unknown fluid however
there is no clear indication of who it
is connected to furthermore they noticed
one of the masked audience members is
wearing a hospital gown there is little
time to assess any of these strange
visuals because there are no trailers or
advertisements before the film as soon
as the audience is settled into whatever
space they might find temporarily
habitable the theater goes silent and
the film Begins the film opens with the
female protagonist going about mundane
activities in her day-to-day life a
phone call interrupts her it is an
unknown party who tells her that a loved
one has been hospitalized for one reason
or another the protagonist drops what
she's doing to accept the call to action
on her way to the hospital however she
is attacked by a male assailant and
loses Consciousness the protagonist
wakes up in a fog unable to make sense
of her surroundings but the audience
understands that wherever she is she is
in
trouble she's in a desolate and
unfamiliar building with her arms and
legs bound she is accompanied by a
number of other female captives some of
whom still remain seemingly unconscious
or possibly dead the woman briefly
discussed their strategy to escape but
they are interrupted when the kidnapper
appears descriptions of hairstyle eye
color and wardrobe would fall short in
showing us who this character really is
instead his Swift and decisive actions
do the talking he sees one of the women
crying and kills her without hesitation
the kidnapper reveals to the woman the
code he intended to operate under he
would release the captives after 24
hours but only under the condition that
they do not cry during the film the
kidnapper demonstrates various forms of
physical and psychological torture on
the group of women despite their best
efforts the captives are unable to hold
back their tears and one by one they are
murdered until only the protagonist
remains frustrated by the protagonist's
unremarkable resolve the kidnapper takes
more Extreme Measures increasing
intensity of her torture however the
protagonist is not one to be messed with
despite being tormented she seems in
control of the situation she doesn't
succumb to the traditional dynamics of
torture even while on the wrong end of
the bat she isn't afraid to swing she
fights back how she can she mocks and
insults her captor and it's then she
finds his weakness although a physically
empowering villain he is emotionally
fragile her grit frustrates him causing
him to lose focus and become noticeably
rattled as the protagonist continues to
weaken her kidnapper with words the
subject in the audience notices what
seems to be a slight echo in the
dialogue they look up to see if
something is wrong with the speakers
they even wonder if this is a stylistic
decision made by the director but then
they notice where it is coming from they
eventually realize that the two masked
women sitting beside them are quietly
repeating every line of dialogue as it
occurs their lips moving causes their
masks to shake softly with each word the
air from their Whispers blows the cloth
away from their mouth only for the mass
to collapse back in when the syllable is
completed if the subject looks even
closer they will see that the lower half
of the woman's masks are saturated with
saliva things don't get any more
pleasant when the subject shifts their
gaze down the woman's body just near
their waists their hands are clasped
together so tightly that their
fingernails are digging into their skin
they tremble and fidget as if having
taken on the burden of the world's
anxiety and no medication can calm them
down fingernails dig deeper into their
skin drawing blood and foreshadowing the
film's finale at the film's climax the
kidnapper approaches the protagonist
with a double-edged razor blade and
announces that even if she is freed she
will spend the rest of her life horribly
disfigured this leads to an argument
between the two the subtexts of which
alludes to themes such as nature of
inner and outer beauty the value of
women in society and the societal stigma
against expressions of vulnerability the
argument on the surface however does not
sound sophisticated or profound there is
no consolation for a fight having
emotional depths at the end of the day
the blows will always feel more physical
than intellectual eventually the
kidnapper loses patience and grabs the
protagonist by the shoulders and slams
her to the floor he reaches out his
hands and grabs her by the face the
subject's attention is again pulled from
the screen when they hear groaning from
every direction the wordless hums filled
the theater with a sense of worry and
uneasiness so much so that the subject
feels the room getting smaller as the
air polluted with angst grows thicker as
the subject brings their eyes back to
the film they see the kidnapper gripping
the protagonist's lower lip between his
thumb and forefinger squeezing tight as
to pop her lip like a balloon the
kidnapper then takes the razor blade to
the victim's lips he pauses to mock the
protagonist and while he does this
blinded by pride and arrogance she jolts
into action grabbing the razor right out
of his hands with her teeth she follows
up her burglary with a salt her neck
stabs forward and in a blur she stabs
the kidnapper's eyes out it happens in
an instant the kidnapper has no time to
react blood spills from his face screams
pour out of his mouth during this time
the protagonist Maneuvers the razor into
her fingers she hacks away at her
bindings but they are stubborn and
resist her sawing the battle continues
and the kidnapper is able to tear off
the victim's lips entirely she looks
like a monster now as the kidnapper
smiles and celebrates his wrongdoings
the protagonist finishes freeing herself
and slits the kidnapper's throat with
the razor the protagonist locates the
exit and scrambles towards it as the
kidnapper bleeds to death on the cold
hard floor the protagonist then speaks
her final words due to her injuries her
voice is muffled and raspy she Bears
down and calmly speaks one last time she
mocks the kidnapper telling him that he
cried tears of blood and therefore had
to die according to his own rules during
this climax it is reported that the
subjects experience a sense of dread
unique to any other Terror ever fight
strangely the film appeared not to
correspond to the scene in the film at
all it is a feeling entirely separate
from the viewing experience as if for a
moment the subject is taken out of the
moment in time and transported to a
realm composed only of fear and anxiety
but just as quickly as they left they
returned the foundation sees it worth
mentioning that this peculiar moment
happens to occur during the film's most
clearly recalled scene while
descriptions of violence vary from one
viewer to the next the climax is
unshakable and its consistency this is
further evidence that scp-5040 has a
core Foundation that remains intact
false memories are given validity by our
peers when we tell a story the
inaccuracies are often the best parts
the exaggerated drama the rearranged
sequence of events the jokes you thought
of in retrospect but weaved into later
accounts while a Storyteller knows when
to lie a good Storyteller knows how to
not get caught
scp-5040 captivates its audience but it
seems to know how much it can get away
with by providing a consistent objective
truth a climax that is reported the same
across all accounts
scp-5040 insists even if only briefly on
being a credible film not just a random
sequence of 24 frames per second eyes
back to the screen the film abruptly
cuts to an unspecified point in the
future now wearing a face mask to hide
her disfigured mouth no different than
the one seen worn in the theater the
protagonist walks down the street to her
apartment indifferent to the crowd of
Paparazzi that follows her it is clear
that this is now just a part of her life
the lights flash on her face when she
reaches her bedroom the protagonist
slowly pulls down her mask face free
from cloth she stares at herself in the
mirror it is silent what she sees is
less notable than what she doesn't the
lower portion of her face is gone she
focuses only on that it's hard to know
if she will ever see into her own eyes
again her gays might forever be fixed on
what she can't get back and through
those eyes that long to see more she
sheds a single tear over the course of
several minutes her weeping gradually
builds into frenzied sobs and shrieks it
can first be misinterpreted as bad
acting a case of doing too much but as
the crying carries onward it's
understood that the horror in her
wallowing is all too real the film cuts
to Black and the credits roll but the
sound of the protagonist's cries
continue to play with no other audio
until the credit reel ends and even then
in silence it's hard to say if she ever
stopped crying audience members remain
silent after the movie ends exchanging
only Whispers as they exit the theater
feet step over small red puddles and
stains on the theater floor as if they
are sticky puddles of soda those who
remain past this point experience an
escalating feeling of unwelcomeness
until sitting and staying is more
physically demanding than getting up and
walking out some experiences will stay
with you forever even if they never
actually happened now go check out
scp-592 inaccurate history book and
scp-2030 laugh is fun for more media
that'll stick in your brain forever